Hey, Jason, did you hear Bennett wants us to do an intro where we're at the dog track? Should we be worried? Right. Well, he's got great creative ideas usually, but he looked a little drowsy this morning. You think he might still be up? It was a long weekend. Well, I'm worried because he keeps mentioning the dog track and I'm like, dude, stop mentioning the dog.
嘿，Jason，你听说了吗？Bennett想让我们在赛狗场录开场白。我们该担心吗？对。嗯，他通常有很多很棒的创意，但他今天早上看起来有点昏昏欲睡。你觉得他是不是还没睡醒？毕竟刚过了一个长周末。嗯，我担心是因为他一直提赛狗场，我就想说，老兄，别再提那条狗了。
Who's going to the dog track these days? We live on the West Coast. We don't go to dog tracks. We don't go to Highlight either, Bennett. Yeah, we're gonna go. Boy, take a nap. God, here come smart lists. Smart.
现在谁还会去赛狗场啊？我们住在西海岸。我们不去赛狗场。我们也不去回力球场，Bennett。是啊，我们要去。天哪，去睡个午觉吧。天哪，智能列表来了。智能。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。智能。少。智能。少。智能。少。智能。
Less. Let me ask you anyway. Yeah. I got it. Why do you wait literally until? I didn't wait. So, listen to me. No, I'm just saying.
少。不管怎样，让我问你一下。好。我明白了。你为什么非要等到最后一刻？我没等。所以，听我说。不，我只是随口一说。
First of all, finish eating. Can I just say something? No, I'm just saying. You always wait until right before we start recording. Just shove eight pounds of food into your hole. Well, listen to me for a second. Yeah. So, it's now, I'm on the East Coast.
首先，先把饭吃完。我能说句话吗？不，我只是随口一说。你总是等到我们要开始录音的时候，才往嘴里塞八磅的食物。好吧，听我说一秒钟。好。所以，现在，我在东海岸。
You guys are on the West Coast. It's one o'clock. So, I was just, I was with all the kids. Mm-hmm. I had four kids walking into town and the dog. Yeah. And it took us 90 minutes to go there and back. And by the time I got back, I thought I'd have more time.
你们在西海岸。现在是一点钟。所以，我刚才，我和孩子们在一起。嗯。我有四个孩子，我们一起走到镇上，还带着狗。对。来回花了90分钟。等我回来的时候，我以为我会有更多时间。
I'm like, shit. And I worked out right before and then I did a five mile walk. So, I'm like. You gotta do it. I gotta eat and I got, I got back. I had four minutes to go. I hastily put together a turkey sandwich on some country white. Okay.
我心想，该死。我刚才锻炼完，然后又走了五英里。所以，我心想。你得做完它。我得吃饭，我回来了。离开始还有四分钟。我匆忙做了一个火鸡三明治，用的乡村白面包。好吧。
A little bit of mayo and some salt and pepper and. Jason's peeing, by the way. That's why we're starting the show already. And so I started with some sliced American and I'm there as well. And then I hammered it down and I didn't bring the house chips, the kettle chips into the equation. But now that you bring it up, I'm going to have a couple. Well, jeez.
加了点蛋黄酱，还有盐和胡椒，然后。顺便说一下，Jason在尿尿。这就是为什么我们已经开始录节目了。所以我开始吃一些切片的美国奶酪，我也在那儿。然后我狼吞虎咽地吃完了，我没把薯片，那种水壶煮的薯片算进去。但既然你提到了，我打算吃几片。好吧，天哪。
Wow. That was a five minute piss and will still eating. Says you. By the way, you have a gallon of electrolytes and you're giving me shit for eating. What the fuck? Drink water. But wait, Will, do you ever, do you guys ever go to like a regular
哇。那可是五分钟的尿尿时间，而且还在吃东西。你说呢。顺便说一下，你有一加仑的电解质饮料，却因为我吃东西而数落我。搞什么鬼？喝水吧。但是等等，Will，你们有没有去过那种正规的
gym? We'll just get back in the gym. You mean, is there like a little setup in your house or do you actually go? And when you go, like I do, like normal people do, are you like a germ phobe? Because I can't. Not in my own house.
健身房？我们还是回健身房吧。你是说，你家里有那种小型的健身设施，还是你真的会去？当你去的时候，像我一样，像正常人一样，你是个洁癖吗？因为我做不到。在我自己家里不行。
I'm not. No, no. But do you ever go to an actual gym? No. Yeah, I don't because of that exact thing. I will say this. I used to. I still do.
我不是。不，不。但你有没有去过真正的健身房？没有。是啊，我没去过，就是因为那个原因。我得说，我以前去过。我现在还去。
I used to go to the gym. I belong to a very popular gym conglomerate for many years. Is it hot dudes? Is it hot dudes? It's called hot dudes.com. Dude, I already tell you this. Yeah, you did. What's the address?
我以前去健身房。我加入过一个非常受欢迎的健身连锁店很多年。是帅哥吗？是帅哥吗？它叫hotdudes.com。老兄，我之前告诉过你这个。是啊，你说了。网址是什么？
Hot easy dudes. Not easy dudes. It was hot. By the way, all dudes are easy. Who's kidding? Who? It's true. Hey, I don't want to paint the picture that, you know, us, you
Hot easy dudes。不是easy dudes。那是hot。顺便说一下，所有的男人都很容易。谁在开玩笑？谁？这是真的。嘿，我不想给人留下那种印象，你知道，我们，你
know, I've been told this in my calling ourselves that Hollywood elites have their own gyms. I'm talking about just like, well, that and also like, you don't need your own, like just running outside or doing a push up or sit up at your house, as opposed to still talking, going to a gym where you're sharing bodily fluids with people. It's just even before the pandemic. You're not sharing bodily fluid.
知道，我被告知过这一点，我们自称好莱坞精英有自己的健身房。我只是在说，嗯，还有，你不需要自己的健身房，只要在外面跑步，或者在家里做俯卧撑或仰卧起坐，而不是像现在还在说话，去一个和别人共用体液的健身房。这甚至在疫情之前就是这样。你没有共用体液。
You're just tired. You are. What are you doing at the gym? Listen, I'm a friendly fella. All right, let's get to it. Will, are you done snacking? Can we go? Listen, I didn't start the show snacking.
你只是累了。你确实是。你在健身房做什么？听着，我是个友善的人。好了，我们开始吧。Will，你吃完零食了吗？我们可以开始了吗？听着，我录节目的时候没吃零食。
I was snacked right before and did it bleed into the show a little bit? Yes. All right, here we go. You guys are, I don't want to tell you how you're going to feel, but you're going to be blown away. I love this guy so much because he is the funniest, most talented person in so many areas.
我是在录之前吃的，它稍微影响到节目了吗？是的。好了，我们开始吧。你们，我不想告诉你们你们会有什么感觉，但你们会被震撼到的。我非常喜欢这个人，因为他是最有趣、最有才华的人，在很多领域都是。
He also has really cool funny hair. And if he's not careful and that's a grow, it will consume his face. But this guy's, okay, how about this? The guy's first gig in the movie business was when he was 16 years old, he wrote music for a horror flick called Night Beast. Huh.
他还有非常酷、非常有趣的头发。如果他不小心，那头发长起来，会把他的脸都盖住。但这家伙，好吧，这个怎么样？这家伙在电影界的第一份工作是他16岁的时候，他为一部叫《Night Beast》的恐怖片写音乐。哈。
He also, I want to ask him about this next thing. He developed or some kind of something for animation, something for Shrek. Nice research. Nice research. Yeah, thanks. By the way, hang on. Wow.
他还，我想问他关于下一件事。他开发了某种东西，用于动画，用于《怪物史莱克》的东西。不错的调查。不错的调查。是啊，谢谢。顺便说一下，等等。哇。
Are you telling me that this guy, something or something, something for Shrek? Yeah, something to do with Shrek. I got to ask him about that. Wow. So wait. And also, Sean, you're the best journalist I've ever met. Also, wait a minute, you guys, listen to this part.
你是说这家伙，某种东西，或者某种东西，为《怪物史莱克》做了什么？是啊，和《怪物史莱克》有关的事情。我得问问他。哇。等等。还有，Sean，你是我见过最好的记者。还有，等等，你们听听这一段。
This guy directed Star Wars, Star Trek, Mission Impossible. It's JJ Abrams. It's JJ Abrams. There we go. Oh my gosh. Wow. Look at this. Look at this fella.
这家伙导演了《星球大战》、《星际迷航》、《碟中谍》。是JJ Abrams。是JJ Abrams。就是他。天哪。哇。看看这个。看看这家伙。
Yeah, he's got a real shallow depth of field on that webcam. I got Darius Kanji to do this podcast. Wow. It's a bit, we appreciate that. You know, it's funny JJ, you always know when I email you because I start every single email I've ever sent you with, hey, JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ. What's up?
是啊，他在那个网络摄像头上的景深很浅。我请了Darius Kanji来做这个播客。哇。这有点，我们很感激。你知道，很有趣，JJ，你总是知道我什么时候给你发邮件，因为我发给你的每一封邮件开头都是，嘿，JJ，JJ，JJ，JJ，JJ，JJ，JJ，JJ，JJ，JJ，JJ。怎么了？
You must love it. It's great. It's funny. Never gets old or funny. What is JJ, by the way? Jeffrey Jacob. Got it. Oh.
你一定很喜欢。太棒了。很有趣。永远不会过时或无聊。顺便问一下，JJ是什么意思？Jeffrey Jacob。明白了。哦。
Never Jacob Jeffrey. No, never. Not once. No, that's because it's not his name. Yeah. How are you guys doing? Real good. We're doing great.
从来不是Jacob Jeffrey。不，从来不是。一次都没有。不，那是因为那不是他的名字。是啊。你们好吗？非常好。我们很好。
How are you, JJ? Wow. I love this podcast. I can't believe you're having me on and I actually think... You haven't listened to this. No. You haven't listened to this. No.
你好吗，JJ？哇。我喜欢这个播客。我不敢相信你邀请我来，而且我实际上认为……你没听过这个。没有。你没听过这个。没有。
But I... Not one thing. No, I will though. It's a great episode. You'll listen to your episode and you'll send us notes. No, it's... Honestly, I love your show. And I'm honored to be here.
但我……一件都没听过。不，但我会听的。这是一集很棒的节目。你会听你那一集，然后给我们提意见。不，它……老实说，我喜欢你们的节目。我很荣幸能来到这里。
You're very sweet. Thank you. We're honored to have you. First thing I want to say, and Sean kind of tipped on right in the intro, how much stuff you've created and worked on and done and how incredibly busy you are. It's unbelievable. And it leads me to my question, which is, I see some guitars in your background. I'm thinking, when the fuck does JJ Abrams have time to play guitar?
你真贴心。谢谢。我们很荣幸能邀请到你。我想说的第一件事，Sean在开场白里提到了，你创造了多少东西，参与了多少工作，做了多少事，而且你忙得不可思议。这太令人难以置信了。这让我想到了我的问题，就是，我看到你背景里有一些吉他。我在想，JJ Abrams到底什么时候有时间弹吉他？
When he's scoring Shrek. I guess. When did you score Shrek? I was in the middle of Shrek and I just got inspired to get a guitar. I didn't know you wrote... But I left out... You also wrote the theme songs to Alias and Lost. Is that true?
当他在给《怪物史莱克》配乐的时候。我想是吧。你什么时候给《怪物史莱克》配乐的？我在做《怪物史莱克》的时候，突然灵感来了，就买了一把吉他。我不知道你写过……但我漏掉了……你还写了《双面女间谍》和《迷失》的主题曲。是真的吗？
I didn't know this about you. What instrument did you start learning and how old were you? I only did those theme songs because I could. Because I was the one who said, okay, no one would ever let me do that. But you can write music? How did you learn music? Was that a thing? I can't read music.
我不知道关于你的这件事。你开始学什么乐器？你多大？我写那些主题曲只是因为我能。因为我是那个说，好吧，没人会让我做那个的人。但你会写音乐？你是怎么学音乐的？那是真的吗？我看不懂乐谱。
I've always played and I always... I remember we had a piano when I was a kid and I would just bang on the piano. My dad would walk by and say, stop. That's encouraging. But I always would think, God, I wish there was a way that that was a string section or something, an orchestra. And later on, I was lucky enough to live in an era where they actually started to make synthesizers and samplers and things where that could actually happen.
我一直都在弹，我一直……我记得我小时候家里有一架钢琴，我就会在钢琴上乱敲。我爸爸走过来说，停下。那真是鼓励人。但我总是想，天哪，我希望有一种方法能让它变成弦乐组或者什么，一个管弦乐队。后来，我很幸运生活在一个他们开始制造合成器和采样器等东西的时代，让这一切成为可能。
Yeah, that's so cool. So now that's what I do. Where did you grow up? Where was that? I was raised in Los Angeles. That's very similar to me. And your parents were in the biz, right? Yeah, my dad still is a TV movie producer, which is unbelievable.
是啊，那太酷了。所以现在这就是我做的。你在哪里长大的？是在哪里？我在洛杉矶长大。那和我非常像。你父母也是圈内人，对吧？是啊，我爸爸现在还是电视电影制片人，这太不可思议了。
He's made a ton of TV movies. Yeah, I didn't know this either. Wow. And my mother was also... She was a lawyer and all sorts of things, but she also was a producer. And so I was very lucky to get to grow up and visit sets. My dad had an office at Paramount Studios when I was young, young. And I remember at like 13, 14, I'd go and visit and I got to know the guards and they'd
他制作了大量的电视电影。是啊，我也不知道这个。哇。我母亲也是……她是一名律师，做过各种各样的事情，但她也是一名制片人。所以我很幸运能长大并参观片场。我年轻的时候，我爸爸在派拉蒙影业有间办公室。我记得在13、14岁的时候，我会去参观，我认识了保安，他们会
let me in to watch them when they were rehearsing like Happy Days and Laverne and Shirley and Mork and Mindy. I went to the Happy Days set once. I mean, it was amazing. Yeah. Wow. What was your memory of that? Oh, just watching Jerry Parris direct and watch these three huge cameras rolling around
让我进去看他们排练，比如《欢乐时光》、《拉弗恩和雪莉》和《莫克和明迪》。我曾经去过《欢乐时光》的片场。我的意思是，那太棒了。是啊。哇。你对那有什么记忆？哦，只是看着Jerry Parris导演，看着这三台巨大的摄像机转来转去
and all the marks on the floor and, you know, really, I mean, it was awesome. Yeah. I mean, and somebody like me, you grew up in the Midwest watching the show. Like I went to a taping of Laughin. That's in the 70s when we were kids. God, you're ancient. Which by the way, you've talked about on this show. Yeah.
还有地板上的所有标记，你知道，真的，我的意思是，那太棒了。是啊。我的意思是，像我这样的人，你在中西部长大，看着那个节目。就像我去看过《Laugh-in》的录制。那是70年代我们还是孩子的时候。天哪，你真是古董。顺便说一下，你在节目里谈到过这个。是啊。
Just to prove that I've listened. Yeah, that's true. Wow. Good for you. Good callback. Oh, that was the Amy Sedet. Okay. Fourteen, three.
只是为了证明我听过。是啊，那是真的。哇。为你点赞。很好的回顾。哦，那是Amy Sedet。好吧。十四，三。
Minute marker. Exactly. But to know that you guys were in the thing that people just watched, like we had no idea how it was made or anything. We were just like, oh my God, look at these characters coming out of our screen. And you guys were there. That's so cool. I always thought that would be a fun book, like called Fourth Wall, that would be like
分钟标记。没错。但知道你们曾经身处人们只是观看的东西中，就像我们根本不知道它是怎么制作的，或者任何东西。我们只是觉得，哦，天哪，看看这些从屏幕里出来的角色。而你们就在那里。那太酷了。我一直觉得那会是一本有趣的书，叫《第四面墙》，就像
what was the fourth wall we never saw of all those sets. Well, you got two guys right here who would never read it. Hey, JJ. It's like flipping the reverse button on the iPhone, right? To see the other way. Yeah, exactly. I would have said like I grew up, I grew up in Toronto and maybe, maybe I'm like the only guy in showbiz.
我们从未见过的所有那些片场的第四面墙是什么。好吧，你这里有两个永远不会读它的人。嘿，JJ。就像翻转iPhone上的反转按钮，对吧？看看另一边。是啊，完全正确。我会说，我长大，我在多伦多长大，也许，也许我是演艺圈里唯一一个
I didn't care. I didn't really care about how it was all made. I didn't really care that much about showbiz. You didn't want another magic trick? Yeah. I don't know. It didn't really. How do you feel about it now?
不在乎的人。我不在乎，我真的不在乎这一切是怎么制作的。我真的不太在乎演艺圈。你不想再看魔术了吗？是啊。我不知道。它真的没有。你现在感觉如何？
I love it. Of course, I love it. And once I started doing it, but it wasn't, when I was younger, I wasn't like enthralled with it. I mean, I need, I grew up watching TV in the seven, I don't know how old, how old you are. I'm 51. So I was born in 70.
我爱它。当然，我爱它。一旦我开始做它，但它不是，当我年轻的时候，我并没有被它迷住。我的意思是，我需要，我在70年代看着电视长大，我不知道你多大，你多大。我51岁。所以我出生于70年。
When I was a kid in the 70s, we watched TV, but I hear about people. I'm like, it wasn't huge in my experience in that way. I don't think I thought about it, the sort of how-to of it at all either until I went to the Universal Studios tour. Because that was the thing that made me realize that it was a thing to do. That God just didn't make episodes of Batman. It was Bert Ward and Adam West and those friends. I did Silver Spoons on the Universal lot and Ricky Schroeder and I used to get sort of the
当我70年代还是个孩子的时候，我们看电视，但我听说过别人。我心想，在我的经历中，它并没有那么巨大。我想我也没有考虑过它的制作方式，直到我去了环球影城之旅。因为那是让我意识到这是一件可以做的事情。上帝并没有制造《蝙蝠侠》的剧集。那是Bert Ward和Adam West以及那些朋友。我在环球影城拍过《银匙》，Ricky Schroeder和我过去常常把
Wiggles out. He was around the back lot there and he had this aquarium in our school room there that had fish in it that would only eat other fish, these just vicious, huge mouth fish. It's such a metaphor. And so we'd go to the Jaws Lake and collect goldfish in plastic bags to feed the fish. So we'd get out in the middle of the lake, which was only about three feet deep. We'd roll up our pant legs and wade and try to get these fish. Eventually, our parents got a letter from Studio Services saying, hey, so we're trying
精力发泄出来。他在外景地附近，他在我们的学校教室里有一个水族馆，里面有鱼，只会吃其他鱼，这些凶猛的、大嘴的鱼。这真是一个隐喻。所以我们会去大白鲨湖，用塑料袋收集金鱼来喂那些鱼。所以我们会走到湖中间，那里只有大约三英尺深。我们会卷起裤腿，涉水，试图抓住这些鱼。最终，我们的父母收到了来自工作室服务部门的一封信，说，嘿，所以我们正试图在电车上吓唬人，当这条大白鲨从湖里出来的时候。当我们两个12岁的孩子在那里，你知道，用网捞金鱼时，这会毁了一切。请把你的狗拴好，好吗？在那些工作室里长大真是太神奇了。这很扭曲，是啊。所以听着，关于那个，关于作为一个孩子，对生意之类的东西产生兴奋感，这就是你对制作东西的吸引力的来源吗？你的父母，你爸爸妈妈在做这件事的事实？
to scare people on the tram when this big white shark comes out of the lake. And it ruins things when we got the two 12-year-olds out there, you know, netting goldfish. Can you lease your dogs, please? That's amazing to grow up on those studio locks. It is twisted, yeah. So listen, so about that, so about being a kid and getting into sort of an excitement about business and stuff, is that where your attraction to making stuff came from, your parents, the fact that your dad and mom was doing it?
这很有趣。我只是记得，你知道，作为一个孩子，去片场，看着，无论是我的父亲在制作的东西，还是我的母亲，或者只是参观，你知道，《莫克和明迪》，看着那些人穿着平民服装排练。就像，我非常渴望成为其中的一部分。很有趣，我记得我父亲指出来，因为我痴迷于像《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》这样的节目。我喜欢那个节目。
It was fun. I just remember being, you know, a kid and going to sets and sort of watching and whether it was something that my father was producing or my mother or just visiting, you know, Mork and Mindy and watching those people in their civilian clothes rehearsing. Like, I just desperately wanted to be part of it. And it's funny, I remember that my father pointed out, because I was obsessed with like the Mary Tyler Moore show. I love that show.
我记得他指出了Jim Brooks的笑声，你知道，他的笑声就是，嗯，嗯，嗯，你知道，他的笑声最神奇的地方是，如果你看任何一集，你在《出租车》和所有东西里都能听到它，就是不仅仅是你听到了他的笑声，而是他笑的地方非常有趣。他会在不仅仅是大众观众笑的时刻笑。就像，他会在事情发生之前笑。他会笑，这是一种奇怪的，我记得小时候，在小学看《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔》的剧集，听到那个笑声。
And I remember that he pointed out Jim Brooks' laugh, you know, and his laugh is just, you know, that, uh, uh, uh, you know, and what's amazing about his laugh, and if you watch any episode, you hear it and taxi and everything, is that it's not just that you hear his laugh, but it was where he laughed that was so interesting. He would laugh in moments that weren't just the sort of mass audience laugh. Like, he would laugh before a thing was happening. And he would laugh and it was this weird, I remember as a kid, like being in an elementary school watching episodes of Mary Tyler Moore and hearing that laugh.
就像，它诉说着排练。它诉说着他知道接下来会发生什么。这是一种对演员的鼓励。它也在调节观众。是啊。但这只是，是啊，这是一种奇怪的事情，就像是《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔》的隐藏字幕过程，仅仅因为那个。但我一直意识到它，但我并没有真的，你知道，决心
And it was like, it spoke of the rehearsals. It spoke of what he knew was coming. It was a kind of encouragement to the actors. It was conditioning the audience too. Yeah. But it was just, yeah, it was this weird sort of thing that was happening that was like, it felt like a closed caption process of like, of Mary Tyler Moore just because of that. But I just, I was always aware of it, but I wasn't really, you know, uh, determined to
参与其中，无论我能做什么，直到我去了环球影城。是啊。喜剧对你来说处于什么位置？我不认为你做过任何喜剧，或者很多喜剧。你想做吗？我从来没做过喜剧，我很想做。喜剧是，你知道，对我来说，显然是《卡罗尔·伯内特秀》。我爱露西。
have some part in it, whatever I could do until I went to Universal Studios. Yeah. Where does comedy sit for you? I don't think you've done any comedies or a lot of comedies. Do you want to? I've never done a comedy and I would love to. Comedy was, you know, for me, obviously the Carol Burnett show. I love Lucy.
《全家福》，所有那些。是啊。每一个Norman Lear的节目。是啊。我痴迷于这一切，我也喜欢《三个臭皮匠》。我只是，有太多，像回首小时候。是的，我会看，你知道，我会看《蝙蝠侠》，我会看《阴阳魔界》。我痴迷于《阴阳魔界》，但是，但是其他一切都是，你知道，老
All in the family, all those. Yeah. Every Norman linear show. Yeah. I was obsessed with all of it and three Stooges I loved. And I just, there were so many, like looking back as a kid. Yes, I'd watch, you know, I'd watch Batman and I'd watch the Twilight Zone. I was obsessed with the Twilight Zone, but, but everything else was, you know, the old
《迪克·范·戴克秀》。我只是喜欢和Jerry Parris交谈。我只是喜欢喜剧。是啊。你，那么那是怎么开始的？所以，你是怎么开始做剧集主管的？首先，我知道那是《费莉希蒂》，第一个是你的节目，你担任剧集主管，你是执行制片人，你创作的？
Dick Van Dyke show. I just loved talking to Jerry Parris. I just love comedies. Yeah. Did you, so how did, how did that start with you then? So like, how did you start as a show runner? First of all, I know that was Felicity, the first show that was yours, that you show ran, that you were EP of, that you created?
那是我和Matt Reeves做的第一件电视作品。我一直在做很多电影，我写过一些，也重写过很多。我处于一种奇怪的循环中，为那些我只是感到灵魂迷失的东西做重写。我心想，我在做什么？那时候你多大？25岁，27岁，随便吧。所以你25岁，27岁。
It was the first TV thing that I did with Matt Reeves. I'd been working on a bunch of movies, I'd written some and I'd been rewriting a bunch. And I was in this kind of weird cycle of doing rewrites for things that I was just sort of feeling lost as a soul. I was like, what am I doing? How old were you at that point? 25, 27, whatever. So you're 25, 27.
你有点像处于这种奇怪的灰色地带，你在做重写，你被雇佣，你是一个重写的人，但你也在试图让电视节目起步。不，我从来没想过做电视。你没想过？没有，我只是碰巧开始写电影，我写了很多，我只是觉得我失去了任何意义或快乐。
You're kind of like in this weird gray area where you're doing rewrites, you're getting hired, you're a, you're a rewrite guy, but you're also trying to get TV shows off the ground. No, I'd never thought about doing TV. You hadn't thought about it? No, I just was, I just happened to get into writing films and I was, I had written a bunch and I was just sort of feeling like I'd lost any sense of purpose or joy in what I was doing.
你在大学学过写作吗？是的，我上过一位我很崇拜的伟大老师的写作课，我不知道我是否会，我会做什么，如果我以为也许我会做一段时间的小说家。我不知道。我只是想做点什么。我在大四的时候觉得，哦，结束了。就像大学快结束了，我最好做一个该死的决定。
Had you studied writing in college? Yes, I took a writing course with a great teacher who I adored and I didn't know if I was going to, what I was going to do, if I thought maybe I was going to be a novelist for a while. I had no idea. I just wanted to do stuff. I was in my senior year feeling like, oh, it's over. Like college is about to end and I better make a fucking decision.
我最好做，你知道，我有一个奇怪的想法，就是，这真是一个奇怪的实际事情。我心想，我需要一个经纪人。我不知道那从哪来的，但我心想，如果我要成功并做任何事情，我需要那个能帮忙的人。大学里没有作家展示会，对吧？没有。他们不会来大学找你。
I better do, you know, and I had this weird thought which is like, and it was such a weird practical thing. I was like, I need an agent. I kind of didn't know where that came from, but I was like, if I'm going to succeed and do anything, I need that person who's going to help. And there's no writer showcase in college, is there? No. They don't come to the college looking for you.
Jason实际上是在问你是否有，因为他之前指出，他什么都不知道，这让他害怕。还有，你们大学教屋顶维修吗？抱歉，这是个玩笑。等等，等等。所以你，但你出来做了这件事，你不知道你想做什么，突然之间，所以你有点像以某种方式回到了《费莉希蒂》，如果你，我把话塞进你嘴里，但是。
Jason's actually asking you if there is because he pointed out before, he doesn't know anything and it scares him. And also, did you guys teach roofing at your college? Sorry, it's a joke. Wait, wait. So you, but you come out and you do this thing, you don't know what you want to do and all of a sudden, so you kind of like back into felicity in a way, if you, I'm putting words in your mouth, but.
发生的事情是我遇到了Katie McGrath，她现在是我的妻子，她。她是最好的。她是所有人中最好的。她是最好的？是啊，她是。在所有人中。完全是，他找到了她。你应该见见她。
What happened was I met Katie McGrath, who is now my wife, and she. She's the best. She's the best of all the people. She's the best? Yeah, she is. Of all the people. Totally, he found her. You should meet her.
她太棒了。所以她提醒了我一件我不该忘记的事情，但我们一次只能记住这么多事情，那就是写你在乎的东西，写你爱的东西。我心想，哦，那件事。所以。要真实，Will。不要满嘴胡言，Will。你知道，发自内心，Will。
She's awesome. So she reminded me of the thing that I should not have forgotten, but we can only remember so many things at one time, which is right things you care about, right what you love. I was like, oh, that thing. So. Be authentic, Will. You don't be full of shit, Will. You know, come from the heart, Will.
继续，JJ。抱歉。请。所以我告诉了我的朋友Matt Reeves，我从我们小时候就认识他，关于这个女孩跟着男孩上大学的想法，就像做一些非常荒谬的事情，犯一个疯狂的错误，但意识到这实际上是对她有好处的事情。总之，所以我们开始谈论那会是什么。我写了这个试播集。
Go ahead, JJ. Sorry. Please. So I told my friend, Matt Reeves, who I had known since we were kids, about this idea of a girl going up following a boy to college, like doing something really ridiculous and making a crazy mistake, but realizing it was something that actually was good for her. Anyway, so we started talking about what that would be. I wrote this pilot.
Matt说他会导演它。我们把它展示给Imagine，他们当时从来没做过电视节目，他们刚带上了一个从来没制作过电视的人，Tony Kranz，来自CAA。他当时是个经纪人。所以我们都没做过电视，突然之间，你知道，他们买了它，而且。所以基本上，Imagine，这是Tracy，那是一家由Ron Howard和Brian Grazer经营的公司，而Ron Howard作为基本上开启电视的人，还没有制作过电视节目。
Matt said he would direct it. We showed it to Imagine, who had never made a television show at that time, and they just brought on someone who had never produced TV before, Tony Kranz, from CIA. He was an agent there. So none of us had made TV before, and suddenly, you know, they bought it and. So basically, imagine, this for Tracy, that's a company run by Ron Howard and Brian Grazer, and Ron Howard being the man who basically started television had not yet produced a television show.
请继续。是啊，我很高兴能和那个我过去看着排练《欢乐时光》的人一起做一个节目。所以我们做了这个节目，这简直是疯狂，因为我们都没做过，所以我们不知道我们在做什么，这真的很有趣。是啊，太酷了。也是巨大的成功。这真的和我朋友，也是你的朋友，Keri Russell一起，我崇拜她，是
Please continue. Yeah, and I was so excited to get to be working on a show with the guy who I used to watch rehearsing happy days. And so we did this show, and it was madness, because none of us had done it, so we didn't know what the hell we were doing, and it was really fun. Yeah, it's so cool. Big success, too. It was really with my friend, and your friend, too, Carrie Russell, whom I adore, one of
最好的人之一。我说不完。我刚听说你妻子，但我一直认为Keri是最好的，但现在我明白了。Keri是另一个最好的人。最好的可以有几百万个。对我来说，她就是最好的。但是，所以，你做，但你做《费莉希蒂》，并获得了巨大的赞誉，我记得当那个节目出来的时候
the best people. I cannot say enough things. I just heard about your wife, but I always thought Carrie was the best, but now I understand that. Carrie is another one of the best. There can be millions of the best. She's just the, to me, she's the best. But so, you do, but you do Felicity, and to great acclaim, I remember when that show came
，显然，那是Keri的第一件大事，它非常巨大，它真的让她出名了，而且，人们谈论你很多。然后，到你做《双面女间谍》的时候，就像是来自JJ。现在它变成了来自JJ Abrams，那个做《费莉希蒂》的家伙。我的观点是，你的轨迹，尽管你在25岁时很不确定，很快你就能以某种方式纠正航向，你开始做《费莉希蒂》，从那一刻起，你有没有感觉到你会成为JJ Abrams，那个不仅引领了《星际迷航》，而且《星球大战》，你做《星际迷航》和《星球大战》的事实是……
out, and it was, obviously, it was the first big thing for Carrie, and it was huge, and it really put her on the map, and also, people were talking about you a lot. And then, to the point that when you did Alias, it was like from JJ. Now it became from JJ Abrams, the guy who did Felicity. My point is, your trajectory, even though you were unsure at 25, pretty soon you were able to sort of course correct, and you start doing Felicity, and from that moment on, did you have any sense that you were going to become JJ Abrams, who not only shepherded Star Trek, but also Star, the fact that you did Star Trek and Star Wars is bogged.
这不可持续，JJ。会发生什么？你不能保持那种轨迹。那不可持续。轨迹是……唯一的路就是向下。你是完全正确的。你肯定会崩溃的。
It's not sustainable, JJ. What's going to happen? You can't keep that trajectory. That is not sustainable. The trajectory is... The only way is down. You're absolutely right. You're going to crash for sure.
但他有Katie。他有Katie在旁边。天哪，我希望你存了钱。我真的希望你存了很多钱。因为我不知道你的月开销是多少，但老实说，我会削减它。哦，天哪，Will，你就像我的良心。我知道。你说的每一件事。
He's got Katie, though. He's got Katie running shotgun. God, I hope you saved money. I really hope you saved a lot of money. Because I don't know what your monthly nut is, but honestly, I'd pare it down. Oh my God, Will, you're like my conscience. I know. Everything you're saying.
我会削减它。就像我晚上睡觉前，每天晚上。你知道，事实是，当我们做《费莉希蒂》时，我们在那个网络上，它不再是WB了。对。而WB做了这件疯狂的事情，我觉得这根本没意义，就是……那只青蛙？那只青蛙是100。
I would pare it down. It's like just before I fall asleep at night, every night. You know, the truth is that when we did Felicity, we were on this network, which is no longer the WB. Right. And the WB did this crazy thing, which I thought was made no sense at all, which is... The frog? The frog was 100.
人们在听，就像，搞什么鬼？Tracy，那只青蛙是WB的吉祥物。好吧，继续。他们会把所有制片人的节目海报和材料都放上去，好像这很重要。对。因为人们，就像没人知道Joss Whedon或Kevin Williamson或JJ Abrams或Matt Reeves，他们把我们的名字放上去，好像它意味着什么。
People are listening like, what the fuck? Tracy, the frog was the mascot of WB. Okay, go ahead. They would put on all of their posters and materials for shows from producers as if it mattered. Right. Because the people, like no one who knew who Joss Whedon or Kevin Williamson or JJ Abrams or Matt Reeves, and they put our names up there as if it meant something.
所以我有点责怪他们，因为它根本没意义。就像，谁在乎它是来自JJ Abrams和Matt Reeves？我们什么都没做。告诉我青蛙喜不喜欢。如果青蛙喜欢，我就看。就像他们需要填补空间还是什么。我不知道。他们没有他们所有的节目。
So I sort of blamed them because it made no sense. It was like, who the fuck cares if it's from JJ Abrams and Matt Reeves? We've done nothing. Tell me if the frog likes it. If the frog's liking it, I'm watching. It was like they needed to fill the space or something. I don't know. They didn't have all their shows.
好吧，那是我们在演艺圈做和看到的事情之一。对于Tracy，当你看到那个说，来自带给你的人，很有可能那些人根本不知道这个东西存在。这很像电影《七宗罪》出来的时候，片头序列太不可思议了。然后做片头序列的人都分成了八家公司。突然之间，每个片头公司都在说，是啊，我们做了《七宗罪》。就像，你知道，来自带给你《七宗罪》片头序列的人，带来了这个片头序列。
Well, that is one of those things that we do and we see in show business. And for Tracy, when you see that thing that says, from the people who brought you, there's a really good chance that those people have no idea that this thing exists. It's a lot like when the movie Seven came out and the title sequence was so incredible. And then the people who did the title sequence all broke up into like eight companies. And suddenly every title company that was out there was like, yeah, we did Seven. It was just like, you know, from the people who brought you the title sequence of Seven comes this title sequence.
这也很像你在城里遇到很多高管。我记得人们就像，你听到就像，你知道，你会看到他们，他们从一家公司搬到另一家公司，然后你会看到《综艺》，他们会有某某。他参与了《发展受阻》。我和Mitch谈过，Mitch会说，我不知道那个人是谁。但他们碰巧在《发展受阻》获得绿灯的那天在楼里，或者随便什么。是啊。
It's also like you meet a lot of executives in this town. I remember people being like, you're hearing like, you know, you'd see them, they'd move from one company to the other and then you'd see Variety and they'd have so-and-so. And he worked on Arrested Development. And I talked to Mitch and Mitch would be like, I have no idea who that person is. But they happened to be in the building the day that Arrested Development was greenlit or whatever. Yeah.
好了。回到节目。JJ，你知道，对我来说，你上播客不仅是一种荣誉，你在这里，真的，而且对我来说很棒。不，有一个转折，JJ。好吧。我们开始吧。是啊，是啊，等着那个转折。
All right. Back to the show. JJ, you know, for me, you being on the podcast is not only just an honor that you're here, truly, but great for me. No, there's a butt coming, JJ. Okay. Here we go. Yeah, yeah, wait for the butt.
是啊。不，是啊，因为它要来了。我得走了，伙计们。得到了好部分。你刚得到了好部分。这是一种荣誉。点击。点击。
Yeah. No, yeah, because it's coming. I got to go, guys. Got the good part. You just got the good part. It was an honor. Click. Click.
那是生存。你得在巅峰时离开。我希望你几年前就学会了。不，所以这对我很棒，因为在播客形式中，我可以问你所有我一直想问你的事情。但当我们社交见面时，我不能真的像，做《星球大战》是什么感觉？是啊。
That is survival. You got to go out on top. I wish you learned that years ago. No, so this is great for me because in the podcast form, I get to ask you all the things I've ever wanted to ask you. But when we see each other socially, I can't really be like, what was it like working on Star Wars? Yeah.
对。但我可以问愚蠢的，愚蠢的问题，就像我一直想知道的两个问题。你小时候最喜欢的电影是什么？你见过的第一部电影是什么？那些对你有启发吗？我想是《欢乐满人间》还是什么。真的？是第一件事。
Right. But I get to ask dumb, dumb questions like I've always wanted to know like two questions. What was your favorite movie as a kid? And what was the first movie you ever saw? And were those inspirations to you? I think Mary Poppins or something. Really? Was the first thing.
但，我记得看《巴黎圣母院》，Charles Lawton的版本，它彻底击垮了我。就像这是一件奇怪的事情，我当时就像，我知道当我在看这个的时候，我当时就像，你知道，七岁还是什么。我知道当我在看的时候，就像这正在击垮我的一生。这就像，这是一个成年人，因为这就像，这是一个关于，你知道，命运和爱和压迫的故事，你知道，我只是记得作为一个孩子，只是感觉我不知道如何处理它，它是如此，它是令人心碎的，而且
But the, I remember seeing the hunchback of Notre Dame, the Charles Lawton version, and it just crushed me. Like it was this weird thing where I was like, I knew while I was watching this, I was like, you know, seven or something. And I knew while I was watching, like this is crushing me for a life. This is like, this is an adult because it's like, this is a story of, you know, of fate and love and oppression and, you know, and I just remember just being this kid, just feeling like I didn't know how to process it was so, and it was heartbreaking and that
这家伙是，你知道，在最后当他就像，你知道，如果我出生时是一块石头，就像，你知道，我是一个水坑，你知道，我想几十年。那是一个沉重的，那是一个沉重的负担。那部电影太棒了。顺便说一下，当你去环球影城之旅时，我喜欢它是《欢乐满人间》或《巴黎圣母院》。但你去环球影城之旅，他们就像，这是我们拍摄《巴黎圣母院》的地方。
this guy was, you know, at the end when he's like, you know, if only I was born as a stone, it's like, you know, I was a puddle for, you know, I think decades. That's a heavy, that's a heavy burden. That movie is amazing. And then by the way, when you go to the Universal Studio Tour, I love that it's Mary Poppins or Hunchback of Notre Dame. But you go to the Hung University Studio Tour and they're like, and this is where we shot Hunchback of Notre Dame.
你就像，什么？就像小时候。我心想，它不在那儿。现在，你是那种看很多电影的人吗？等等，等等，等等，等等，他得回答他最喜欢的电影是什么。哦，是啊。我想，你知道，我小时候很喜欢，如果你问我小时候。两者，既是小时候，也是有史以来。
You're like, what? It was like as a kid. I'm like, it wasn't there. Now, are you the kind of guy that watches a bunch of movies? Wait, wait, wait, wait, he's got to answer what his favorite film was. Oh yeah. I think, you know, I loved as a kid, if you're asking me as a kid. Both, both as a kid, but also of all time.
嗯，我最喜欢的电影之一是《费城故事》，我疯狂地喜欢它。Tom Hanks，Tom Hanks，和Denzel Washington，简直是精彩的表演。还有《西北偏北》。《西北偏北》。《西北偏北》。《西北偏北》。是啊。
Well, one of my favorite movies of all time is Philadelphia Story, which I loved like crazy. Tom Hanks, Tom Hanks, and Denver, Washington, just fantastic performances. And North by Northwest too. North by Northwest. North by Northwest. North by Northwest. Yeah.
你呢？North，是啊。由Rob Reiner导演。Rob Reiner。他做到了。哦不，那是《North》。当我小时候，我，我11岁，在我11岁生日那天。我哥哥带我。
What about you? North, yeah. By Rob Reiner. Rob Reiner. He killed it. Oh no, that's North. When I was a kid, I was, I was 11 years old for my 11th birthday. My brother took me.
你11岁生日那天11岁？嗯。谢谢。没门。我哥哥带我。你父母在那件事上多幸运，对吧？抱歉。是啊，学校没浪费在我身上。
You were 11 years old for your 11th birthday? Mm-hmm. Thank you. It's no way. My brother took me. How lucky were your parents on that, right? Sorry. Yeah, school wasn't wasted on me.
我去，我哥哥带我去看《E.T.》过生日，我坐在那里，电影院里的每个人在最后E.T.离开而Elliot在那里时都在哭。我对哥哥说，我说，哦，天哪，我愿意付出一切成为那个孩子，对吧？他说，是啊，Elliot，那是，所有这些孩子可能都想成为Elliot并有那种经历。那多酷啊。我说，不，我愿意付出一切成为Henry Thomas。就像我在11岁时就知道，我想成为一名演员，这就是那种感觉。
I went to go, my brother took me for my birthday to see E.T. and I'm sitting there and everybody in the theater all crying at the end when E.T. leaves and Elliot's there. And I said to my brother, I said, oh my God, I'd give anything to be that kid, right? And he goes, yeah, Elliot, that's, all these kids probably want to be Elliot and have that experience. How cool is that? And I go, no, I'd give anything to be Henry Thomas. Like I knew at 11 years old, I wanted to be an actor and that's what's like.
他面前的机会。我想成为那个孩子。是啊。天哪。没门。是啊，是啊。我也告诉过Spielberg那个故事。我刚才在告诉我的孩子们，我们正在这次大步行中，我在谈论，
The opportunities ahead of him. I wanted to be that kid. Yeah. God. No way. Yeah, yeah. I told Spielberg that story too. I was just telling my kids, we were walking in on this big walk and I was talking about,
他们问关于《星球大战》。我11岁的孩子问我关于《星球大战》，我说这是我记得在电影院看的第一部电影，也是我见过的唯一一部电影。我在电影院看了四次，他们带我整个，那是1977年，所以我7岁。我整个学校都去看它，因为它是一个如此的现象。没人见过，我正试图告诉我的孩子们，没人见过像它之前那样的东西。没有别的，没有别的参考框架。
they were asking about Star Wars. My 11 year olds asked me about Star Wars and I said it was the first film that I remember seeing in the theater and it was the only film that I've ever seen. I saw it four times in the theater and they took my whole, that was 1977, so I was seven. My whole school went to see it because it was such a phenomenon. Nobody had seen, and I was trying to say to my kids, nobody had seen anything like it before. There was nothing else, there was no other sort of frame or reference for it.
它把一切都吹走了，现在当然，你知道，周五我儿子在等《黑寡妇》，或者他们每天在等《洛基》出来，你知道。但那时，这鬼东西，那太不可思议了。我不知道你是否记得，作为一个现在是《星球大战》导演并参与整个《星球大战》机器的人，你记得它在那个年龄对你的生活有影响吗？哦，天哪。不仅是它。我的意思是，对于我们这一代的任何人，它显然是如此巨大和疯狂的变革
It blew everything away and now there's so, of course, you know, Friday my son is waiting for Black Widow or they're waiting for Loki to come out every day, you know. But back then, this shit, that was incredible. I don't know if you remember, as a guy who's now a director in the Star Wars and part of the whole Star Wars machine, do you remember having an impact on your life at that age? Oh my God. Not only was it. I mean, for anyone of our generation, it was obviously such a massive and insane transformative
东西，那些电影在电影院上映了一年多。是啊，对吧。就像它们出来，它们就呆在那里，你知道，这太疯狂了。是啊，那不是大片这个词的来源吗？是啊，《大白鲨》是，哦，《大白鲨》是因为它在街区周围，队伍在街区周围。哦，是这样吗？哦，天哪。
thing and those movies were in the theater for over a year. Yeah, right. Like they'd come out and they'd just stay, you know, which is crazy. Yeah, isn't that where the term blockbuster was? Yeah, JAWS was the, oh JAWS was because it was around the block, the line was around the block. Oh, is that right? Oh my God.
我只是，等等，等等，那是真的吗？在那一刻我感觉自己像个Tracy。是啊。我想那是真的。天哪。JJ，你知道那个问题的答案吗？那是真的吗？我相信那是答案。
I just, wait, wait, is that true? I just felt like such a Tracy in that moment. Yeah. I think that's true. My God. JJ, do you know the answer to that question? Is that true? I believe that that's the answer.
是啊。队伍在街区周围。是啊。我想这说得通。Sean，看，Will，他不笨。我不知道。我知道。我知道。
Yeah. Lines were on the block. Yeah. I guess that makes sense. Sean, see, well, he's not stupid. I don't know. I know. I know.
我知道。我对我刚才发给你的短信感到难过。我对刚才发出的最后一条短信感到非常难过。我能告诉你吗，JJ，我得说，我喜欢，首先，我们并不真正认识。多年来我们互相打过很多次招呼，但有一次，我们的一位共同朋友。我不知道你是否记得这个。我们的一位共同朋友大约10、12年前，给每个人发了一封电子邮件
I know. I feel bad about my text I just sent you. I feel really bad about that last text I just sent. Can I tell you, JJ, I gotta say, I love, first of all, we don't really know each other. We've said hi to each other a bunch of times over the years, but there was a time, a mutual friend of ours. I don't know if you remember this. A mutual friend of ours about 10, 12 years ago, was sending an email out to everybody
他忘了密送。所以我们抄送了所有人。所以他地址簿里A和B里的每个人都收到了这封邮件，我们都看到了彼此的电子邮件地址，它包括你和我，还有那个做《拆弹部队》的女人，那个伟大的导演。Kathryn Bigelow。是啊。Kathryn Bigelow。
and he forgot to BCC. So we CC'd everybody. So everybody in the A's and B's in his address book got sent this email and we all saw each other's email address and it included you and me and it was the woman who did Hurtlocker, that great director. Katherine Bigelow. Yeah. Katherine Bigelow.
不敢相信我忘了她的名字。Annette Bening，还有其他很多人。所以他立刻说，哦，天哪，我很抱歉，我说，我忘了，我应该密送，但我抄送了，我很尴尬。我当时发了一封电子邮件，我挑出了很多人，我说，嘿，听着，Kathryn Bigelow，大粉丝，嘿Annette Bening，我有一半剧本。如果你有一分钟，我很想给你。我对JJ说，嘿，我能，我想参与一些那种太空鬼东西吗？
Can't believe I forgot her name. Annette Benning, a bunch of other people. So he immediately said, oh my gosh, I'm so sorry that I said, I forgot, I should have BCC'd and I CC'd and I'm so embarrassed. And I sent out an email at the time and I singled out a bunch of people and I was like, hey, listen, Katherine Bigelow, big fan, hey Annette Benning, I've got half a script. I'd love to get to you if you've got a minute. And I said to JJ, hey, can I want to be in some of that space shit?
我只是无聊，我把它发了出去，对吧？你立刻回复了所有人，你太搞笑了。你就像，你加入了。你好，Blah。我需要你的尺寸。你太超级有趣了，而且你看起来总是非常，非常脚踏实地，对于，我只是喜欢你这一点，你，我想说这个，你有很棒的氛围。你有很棒的氛围。
I was just bored and I sent it out, right? You immediately responded to all and you were hilarious. You're like, you're in. Hello, Blah. I need your sizes. You were so super funny and you always seem really, really down to earth for, I just love that about, you've got, I want to say this, you got great vibe. You've got great vibe.
那太慷慨了。是啊，那是真的。谢谢。而且是啊，没关系。即使我们不认识，我总是觉得我们认识，这完全是没根据的。一样。我知道。
That's very generous. Yeah, that's true. Thank you. And yeah, it's fine. Even though we don't know each other, I always sort of feel like we do, which is completely unworn. Same. I know.
好吧，我也是个温暖的人。所以我认为我们都是温暖的人。在我见到你并确认你有多伟大、温暖和可爱之前，我多年来一直从Grumburg那里听说过，你们一直。Greg Grumburg。Greg Grumburg。Greg Grumburg。他是你的朋友。
Well, I'm a warm guy too on top of it. So I think we're both warm guys. And before I ever met you and confirmed how great and warm and cuddly you were, I'd always heard about it from Grumburg all these years that you guys had been. Greg Grumburg. Greg Grumburg. Greg Grumburg. He's a friend of yours.
而且我本身也是个热情的人。所以我认为我们俩都是热情的人。在你我相识并确认你有多棒、多热情、多讨人喜欢之前，这些年来我一直从格伦伯格那里听说你们俩的关系。格雷格·格伦伯格。格雷格·格伦伯格。格雷格·格伦伯格。他是你的朋友。
He's an actor and he's, you guys were roommates together, right? You guys have stayed so close for so long. I just think that's such a great, great sign of someone. He's, we met in kindergarten and, you know, it's just, it's surreal to now be old men. Yeah. Right. We've known each other for so long. It's so bizarre because, you know, you see that our kids are now so much, you know, older
他是个演员，你们以前是室友，对吧？你们俩这么多年一直保持着这么亲密的关系。我觉得这真的能很好地体现一个人的品质。我们是在幼儿园认识的，你知道，现在变成老头子了，感觉真是不真实。是啊，没错。我们认识太久了。这太奇怪了，因为你知道，你会发现我们的孩子现在比我们刚认识时大多了。
than we were when we met. Right. And it's like, you know, it just confirms that we're all going to die. That's really how I see it. But JJ, to all of that, to the point of all of that, who in the world taught you how to manage so many personalities with a smile on your face? Because you always do. Everyone that deals with you feels respected and valued.
比我们当时大多了。没错。这就像是在确认我们终究都会老去。我确实是这么看的。但是JJ，说到这一切，说到这些重点，到底是谁教你如何带着微笑处理这么多复杂的人际关系的？因为你总是能做到。每一个和你打交道的人都感到被尊重和重视。
And I've seen it firsthand. You're always so kind and generous and giving people time to listen to them and respect them. And of course, that makes you an enemy. I'm sorry. I just wasn't listening. What were you listening to? An even better director.
我亲眼见证过。你总是那么善良、慷慨，愿意花时间倾听他人并尊重他们。当然，这让你树敌不少。抱歉，我刚才没在听。你在听什么？听一位更好的导演说话。
So who is, is there something or somebody that taught you that? This is the truth. I'm so grateful that you, again, super generous and probably not warranted. What I would say is this, is that everyone has their own different reasons for getting into this business and for doing whatever they do or at least wanting to get into the business. Of course, there are no guarantees. And I know for me, it was that I just never, I was never good at anything in school.
那么，有没有什么事或什么人教过你这些？说实话，我真的很感激你，再次强调，你太慷慨了，而且可能有些过誉了。我想说的是，每个人进入这个行业、做他们所做的事情，或者至少想要进入这个行业，都有各自不同的原因。当然，没有什么是有保证的。我知道对我来说，是因为我在学校里什么都不擅长。
I was not a very popular student. I was not a very popular social kid. I was awful in any sports context. It was just one of those things where like, I just knew, I remember being in elementary school, literally walking through. I remember where I was when I had this epiphany and I was like, I just remember, this is not my moment. Like just fucking get through this.
我不是一个很受欢迎的学生。我不是一个很受欢迎的社交型孩子。我在任何体育运动方面都很糟糕。就是那种感觉，我记得在小学时，真的走在路上，我记得当时我有这种顿悟，我当时想，我记得，这不是我的时刻。就像是，去他妈的，熬过去吧。
Like I remember feeling like I can't, this is not, and when you're a kid that is either, you know, bullied or not particularly popular and it's not like I didn't have some friends. It's not like I wasn't a happy kid, but like, I just- You had Grunberg, but you guys were not crushing ass is what you're saying. Grunberg was doing great. I mean, Grunberg, he was one of those kids that like, no matter what we played, Greg was like a superhero. So he'd get up to bat and he just knew that that ball was going to just go, it would land
我记得那种感觉，我做不到，这不是我的时刻。当你是一个被欺负或者不太受欢迎的孩子时，并不是说我没有朋友。也不是说我不是个快乐的孩子，但我只是——你有格伦伯格，但你们当时并不是那种风云人物，你是这个意思吧？格伦伯格表现得很好。我是说，格伦伯格，他是那种无论我们玩什么，格雷格就像超级英雄一样的孩子。所以他上场击球时，他就是知道那球会飞，它会落到
into another school. And I was just a kid that was going to strike out. So he carried you early on and now you're carrying him. That's kind of a great- Yeah. Honestly, he was always, you know, a great friend, but it's not even that. It's just that feeling of knowing what it's like to not participate. Yeah.
另一所学校里。而我只是那个会三振出局的孩子。所以他早期带着你，现在你带着他。这真是一种很棒的——是啊。老实说，他一直是个好朋友，但甚至不仅仅是这样。这只是一种知道什么叫“无法参与”的感觉。是啊。
And I think that when you're someone who, I mean, who knows what, but when you're someone who isn't particularly seen or getting any kind of respect, like you just, you feel for and have compassion for people who are, for people. Yeah. And since some people, when they're given the privilege of oversight and leadership, they will now exercise all the bitterness that they have and make everybody pay, although some people like yourself, remember that experience, hold on to that empathy, they relate to that and then they then make that circumstance better for everyone later.
我觉得当你是一个，谁知道呢，但当你是一个不太被看见，或者得不到任何尊重的人时，你就会对那些同样处境的人产生同情。是啊。有些人在获得监督和领导的特权时，会发泄他们所有的苦涩，让每个人都付出代价；而有些人，像你一样，记得那种经历，保持着同理心，他们会产生共鸣，然后让每个人的处境变得更好。
Yeah. And that's why you're a great leader. I think. It's nice of you to say. I mean, I'm also, you know, obviously equally, you know, frustrated and yeah, not tyrannical, but like, you know, I'm, Katie's going to cover it all in her book. You don't, you don't need to waste your time here. Oh, she, dude, do not mention her book.
是啊。我想这就是你成为伟大领导者的原因。你这么说真是太好了。我是说，我也同样，你知道，显然也同样感到沮丧，是的，不是暴君，但你知道，我，凯蒂会在她的书里写到这一切。你不需要在这里浪费时间。哦，她，伙计，别提她的书。
He doesn't know her book. Guys, is there a book? I will say this. JJ, what do you think about this? So Jason's got this theory that once he's had a certain level of success, it will afford him the ability to then be very generous with other people. But he's. Still waiting.
他不知道她的书。伙计们，有书吗？我会说这个。JJ，你怎么看？杰森有个理论，一旦他取得了一定程度的成功，他就有能力对其他人非常慷慨。但他还在等。
True. By the way, it's true. Right. Wait. Jason, what's the theory again? You said it to Ron. You can't wait to be. Well, I said, I said when I was, I was sitting there with things were not going great for
真的。顺便说一句，这是真的。对。等等。杰森，那个理论是什么来着？你对罗恩说过。你迫不及待地想成为。嗯，我说过，我说当我在，我坐在那里，事情对我来说一点都不顺利的时候。
me whatsoever. And I was confused about whether I should posture when I go into auditions and I should act like I don't really want it, but inside I was desperate for it. And I was watching him do an interview once and he was so frigging, kind and warm and unassuming as he always has been. And I remember watching that going, God, I so badly want to be that kind and that warm because that's how I feel inside. But I feel like if I go into these auditions and I'm that nice, they're going to think
我感到困惑，不知道去试镜时是否应该摆姿态，应该表现得好像我并不真的想要这个角色，但内心却渴望得要命。我曾经看过他的一次采访，他表现得那么亲切、温暖、谦逊，一如既往。我记得看着那个画面想，天哪，我太想变得那么亲切、那么温暖了，因为那是我内心的真实感受。但我觉得如果我去试镜时表现得那么好，他们会觉得
I'm desperate. And so I thought if I ever had success where people wouldn't misunderstand that, then I can be as kind as I want to. And I don't know if I'm there yet, but, you know, Will's laughing his ass up. It was a real deep moment for me. It's my favorite. Motherfucker. It's my favorite.
我很绝望。所以我当时想，如果我有一天成功了，人们就不会误解这一点，那时我就可以随心所欲地表现得善良。我不知道我是否已经到了那个阶段，但是，你知道，威尔笑得前仰后合。那对我来说是一个非常深刻的时刻。这是我最喜欢的。混蛋。这是我最喜欢的。
Look at the, you can just see the blackness in his heart right there. How does that laugh? It's the laughing. I want to get to the stuff that I want to ask you. Do you have any great Broadway stories? Actually JJ, JJ produced a great, great, great Broadway show called called the play that goes wrong. The play that goes wrong.
看，你一眼就能看到他内心深处的黑暗。那笑声是怎么回事？就是那笑声。我想谈谈我想问你的事情。你有什么很棒的百老汇故事吗？其实JJ，JJ制作了一部非常非常棒的百老汇剧，叫《演砸了》。《演砸了》。
It is a huge physical farce and it's hilarious. Really? It's great. And was that the first Broadway show you produced? That was the first one yet. Yeah, and then we did the Darren Brown secret show too, which was really amazing. Wait, you did? Yeah.
那是一部大型肢体闹剧，非常搞笑。真的吗？太棒了。那是你制作的第一部百老汇剧吗？那是第一部。是的，然后我们还做了达伦·布朗的秘密秀，也非常精彩。等等，你做了那个？是的。
Do you know him? I do. I've known Darren for a long time. That guy is amazing. So JJ, I have a question about stepping up from something that would seem to me very sort of manageable as far as scale goes as a director and then making a leap into an apparatus as enormous as the things that you are now rightly known for. And to make it relatable for those that might not be in the industry, can you talk a little
你认识他吗？我认识。我认识达伦很久了。那家伙太棒了。所以JJ，我有个问题，关于从一个作为导演来说规模上看起来非常可控的事情，跨越到像你现在理所当然闻名的那些巨大装置中去。为了让那些不在这个行业的人也能产生共鸣，你能谈谈
bit about what it is that makes you capable of taking on an enormous amount of responsibility and to Sean's sort of earlier question embracing that kind of responsibility of leadership. And just for listeners out there that might find themselves in a moment right now where they could either step forward into something that might be a little bit uncomfortable, but they think they might be capable of it. And what's that process for you? Well, look, obviously all creative endeavors and collaborations are a leap of faith. You just don't know what's going to happen really until you're in it.
是什么让你有能力承担如此巨大的责任，以及回应肖恩之前关于拥抱那种领导责任的问题吗？对于那些可能正处于某个时刻，既可以向前迈出一步去尝试一些可能有点不舒服，但他们认为自己可能有能力做到的事情的听众，对你来说那个过程是什么样的？嗯，看，显然所有的创意努力和合作都是一种信仰的飞跃。你真的不知道会发生什么，直到你身处其中。
And what I found is that there's actually very little difference between doing something as relatively small as Felicity or Alias and doing something that is far bigger like a Star Wars or Star Trek movie that, of course, there are a million differences and yet the fundamentals are the same. And I just feel like, in a way, it's less about the managing. I did this years ago, I did this panel with Chris Rock and someone asked, how do you hire people to work with? How do you find them?
我发现，做像《幸福》或《双面女间谍》这样相对较小的事情，和做像《星球大战》或《星际迷航》电影这样大得多的事情，其实差别很小。当然，有一百万个不同之处，但基本原则是一样的。我只是觉得，在某种程度上，这与其说是管理。我几年前做过这个，我和克里斯·洛克一起参加了一个小组讨论，有人问，你如何雇佣一起工作的人？你怎么找到他们？
And Chris said this thing, which I thought was so smart, which was that he's like, I try to hire my boss. I try to hire this someone that's going to show me how it's done, like not the person I have to, and I think that's when you work with people who are as talented. It takes courage to do that though, you know? Well, but I guess it does on one hand, but to me, honestly, it's like it is so moronic to go into something that is so enormous where everyone is the same importance and to not have people who will show you or offer better ideas is insane.
克里斯说了这样一件事，我觉得非常聪明，他说，我试着雇佣我的老板。我试着雇佣那种能向我展示事情该怎么做的人，而不是我必须去教的人。我觉得当你和那些有才华的人一起工作时，就是这样。但这需要勇气，你知道吗？嗯，我想一方面确实如此，但对我来说，老实说，去参与一件如此巨大的事情，每个人都同样重要，却不找那些能向你展示或提供更好想法的人，这简直是疯了。
So for me, every time I'm working on anything of any scale and I feel freaked out or unsure or adrift, I look around and I find incredible comfort in that. So I think that the analogy, it's like once you have led, there are teachers out there and if you can wrangle a classroom of students, you can probably manage almost anything. There's a kind of, I think, through line to just knowing how to deal with people and how to spin plates and make sure that things are juggling a lot of stuff. But the truth is that the process, of course, the stories are different, the sets look different, the special effect budget slightly higher on Star Wars and Felicity, but when you're
所以对我来说，每当我从事任何规模的工作，感到惊慌、不确定或迷茫时，我环顾四周，从中找到了难以置信的安慰。所以我认为这个类比是，一旦你领导过，外面就有老师，如果你能管好一教室的学生，你可能就能管理几乎任何事情。我认为有一种贯穿始终的东西，就是知道如何与人打交道，如何旋转盘子，确保事情在处理很多杂事。但事实是，过程当然不同，布景看起来不同，《星球大战》的特效预算比《幸福》稍微高一点，但当你
working on things like that, the experience of just trying to tell a story, having a camera on two people, it's weirdly, the important stuff is weirdly the same. Did you find it difficult for a star working on Star Wars and Star Trek to kind of navigate, wanting to tell your own original story as a director, but that was created by somebody else because there's so many people coming to you every direction, like why would you want that job? It just seems, what made you say yes? Huberess and stupidity probably, the truth is, and you all sort of know this in different
从事这样的工作时，那种试图讲故事、把摄像机对准两个人的体验，奇怪的是，重要的事情奇怪地是一样的。你觉得在制作《星球大战》和《星际迷航》时，作为导演想要讲述自己的原创故事，但这些故事又是别人创造的，这很难驾驭吗？因为有那么多人从各个方向找你，为什么你会想要那份工作？这看起来，是什么让你说了“是”？大概是傲慢和愚蠢吧，事实是，你们都以不同的方式知道这一点，
ways, when you get involved in something that pre-exists you, you're immediately on your heels because no matter what you do, someone's taking it personally. And we live in a world where you hear about it too. There's no quiet. There are no internal thoughts anymore. And so that is, that's a fucking nightmare. That aspect is awful. But the truth is, and I'm not joking when I say Huberess because to say yes to something
当你参与到先于你存在的事物中时，你立刻就处于被动地位，因为无论你做什么，总有人会把它个人化。我们生活在一个连这些你都能听到的世界里。没有安静。再也没有内在的想法了。所以那是，那真是个该死的噩梦。那方面太糟糕了。但事实是，我说傲慢并不是在开玩笑，因为对某件事说“是”
that is not just enormous and a religion for people, but also that has a release date and not a script. But having walked through that fire and landed in such success, can you say to that listener out there that don't worry the confidence that you wish you'd had at the beginning actually exists on the backside of walking through something that you wonder if you can handle? Two things. I think that both the sense of confidence can be the greatest asset, and it can also be the thing that blinds you to the reality that you're only human and you can only do
不仅是巨大的，对人们来说是一种宗教，而且还有一个上映日期，却没有剧本。但走过那场火并取得了如此成功之后，你能对那位听众说，别担心，你希望在开始时拥有的那种自信，实际上存在于走过你怀疑自己能否处理的事情之后吗？两件事。我认为自信感既可以是最大的资产，也可能是让你对“你只是凡人，在有限的时间内只能做有限的事情”这一现实视而不见的东西。所以你看，这不是，当你参与其中时，这是一件有趣的事情，我相信你们也有过类似的经历，所以我不是在抱怨，但我知道这很常见。但是当你参与到对人们很重要的事情中时，无论你说什么，无论你说什么，它都会以某种方式被断章取义，然后被扭曲。有很多我热爱和钦佩的记者，特别是在这个记者们被狠狠打击的时刻，我认为庆祝他们比以往任何时候都更重要。
so much in so much time. And so I look, and this is not, it's a funny thing when you get involved, I'm sure you've had versions of this too, so I'm not complaining about this, but I know it's common. But when you're involved in things that matter to people, no matter what you say, no matter what you say, it is somehow taken out of context and then spun. And there are so many reporters who I love and admire, and especially in this moment when journalists are getting their asses kicked, it's more important, I think, than ever to celebrate them.
然而，有些记者只是点击诱饵的妓女，说实话，他们会这么做。我被某人采访时，他们问，你对那些讨厌《最后的绝地武士》的人说什么，因为他们认为这是女权主义宣传之类的？我说，什么？我说，我想如果你讨厌一部《星球大战》电影，因为你可能对它有更大的问题。标题就变成了，JJ·艾布拉姆斯说，如果你不喜欢《最后的绝地武士》，你就是反女权主义者。
And yet, there are some that are just clickbait whores, let's be honest, and we'll do it. I was being interviewed by someone and they were like, what do you say to people who hated the last Jedi because they think it's a feminist propaganda or something? I was like, what? And I said, I think if you hate a Star Wars movie because you probably have bigger problems with it. And the headline was like, Jay Jay Abrams, Colin, if you didn't like the last Jedi, you're anti-feminist.
就像是，我当时想，天哪，这是一个令人难以置信的数学问题，你刚刚……嗯，这就是问题所在，我们所处的这个世界，其中一件事，顺便说一下，你应该知道我正在进行一场十字军东征，想在我现在居住的这个小镇上被任命为副警长，因为我想四处走动，我要花我所有的时间，我一直在和伙计们谈论这件事，去抓那些不打转向灯的人，我要……顺便说一下，等等，等等，我必须说一件事，这让我发疯。
It was like, I was like, holy mother of God, that's an incredible math problem that you just... Well, here's the problem, the world we exist in, one of the things, and I'm, by the way, you should know I'm on this crusade to get deputized in this small town on these coasts that I'm living in right now for the moment, because I want to go around, I'm going to get people, I'm going to spend all my time, I keep talking about it with the guys, getting people for not using their blinker, and I'm going to... By the way, wait, wait, I have to say one thing, so this makes me insane.
这个不打转向灯，转向灯不重要，那个反转向灯运动，我想说的是……等等，什么？我没听说过这个。你在说什么？我也没听说过。人们不打该死的转向灯。我的意思是，我不知道什么时候向那些生命掌握在你手中的人类发出信号“我要左转”变得不酷了。我正在填满监狱。所以事情是这样的，特斯拉显然有……你可以制作自己的喇叭，你不觉得人们应该把转向灯当作喇叭吗？哦，那太棒了。我很乐意带你进来。这让我发疯。
This not blinker, blinkers don't matter, the campaign, the anti-blinkers, what I would say is this... Wait, what? I have not heard about this. What are you talking about? I haven't heard either. People don't use the fucking blinker. I mean, it's like, I don't know when it became uncool to signal to human beings whose lives
我要带你进来向社区讲话。天哪。等等，我是怎么开始这个问题的？我有一个非常好的问题，然后我们只是……是啊，你在谈论评论家。哦，评论家。我想说的是，我们生活在这个世界里，评论家们当然在寻找点击诱饵，因为他们的生计取决于此，对吧？
are in your hands, I'm turning left. I'm filling the jails. So here's the thing, the Tesla apparently has the... You can make your own horn, don't you think that people should have used your blinker as the horn? Oh, that's great. I'd love to bring you in. It makes me nuts.
所以他们可以去，无论他们为谁工作，都可以看看数据，说，你的故事没有被点击。因此……顺便说一下，这也适用于评论。你可以读到一部电影的好评，但标题却很糟糕。但我认为这是金钱腐蚀另一件事的又一种方式。完全正确。这一切都是关于点击量，不仅仅是点击量。
I'm going to bring you in to speak to the community. Oh my God. Wait, how did I start this question? I had a really great question and then we just got... Yeah, you were talking about critics. Oh, critics. I was going to say, we live in this world where the critics, of course, they're looking for clickbait because their livelihood depends on it, right?
就像，嗯，如果你得到很多点击，你就能保住工作……是的。一切都被腐蚀了。这很好……不过，烂番茄通过汇总所有这些采访并将它们简化为一个数字，在某种程度上缓解了这一点，这很好。有一点，但仍然是那些人。但是JJ，让我问你这个。
So they can go, whomever it is that they work for can take a look at the data and say, your stories aren't getting clicked on. So therefore... And by the way, that goes for reviews, too. You can read a good review for a film that has a bad headline. But I think it is yet another way that money has corrupted yet another thing. It's exactly right. It's all about the clicks aren't just clicks.
所以说了这一切，并顺着杰森说的话，再次强调，这是为了特雷西，为了我们所有的听众，也为了我，有没有一些时刻你可以客观地回顾并说，哇，我做了很多很酷的事情，我做了一些伟大的事情。你有那些时刻吗？我知道很多人说，嗯，我真的不能。我得保持踩油门之类的。但你做了很多非常酷的事情。
It's like, well, you're going to keep your job if you get a lot... Yeah. Everything has been corrupted. It's a nice... It's nice, though, that Rotten Tomatoes has somewhat mitigated that by aggregating all these interviews and just reducing them down to just a number. A little bit, but it's still those same people. But Jay-Z, let me ask you this.
你曾经允许自己那样吗，我是说，完全允许？你这么说真是太好了，但老实说，这根本不是我看待我所做事情的方式。我的意思是，我知道我得到了难以置信的机会，当然还有机会去做一些我不知道自己是否一定应得的事情，当然还有其他人比我更应得。但当我被要求执导一部《碟中谍》电影时，当汤姆·克鲁斯给我那个机会时，那是我永远无法预料到的。
So having said all of this and kind of going off what Jason said, and again, this is for Tracy and for all our listeners and for me, too, are there moments that you can go back and you can look objectively and say, wow, I've done a lot of pretty cool things and I've done some great things. Do you have those moments? And I know a lot of people say, well, I can't really. I got to keep the pedal down and stuff. But you've done a lot of really cool things.
而且就在他问我的前一天，我永远无法预料到。我根本不知道那会发生。真的吗？完全不知道。他给了我一个预告，但我希望你感到惊讶。你不想吓到他。是的，我不想吓到他。我希望它很特别。
Do you ever allow yourself that, I mean, at all? It's incredibly nice of you to say that, but honestly, it is so not how I see what I have done. I mean, I know I've been given incredible opportunities and certainly chances to do things that I don't know if I necessarily deserved and certainly there were other people who deserved more than I did. But when I was asked to direct a Mission Impossible movie, when Tom Cruise gave me that opportunity, that was something that I could never have predicted.
我们喜欢那个。我们喜欢你和凯莉一起拍的那部。哦，是的，她在里面表现得太好了。但我的观点是，我觉得我得到了难以置信的机会，所以我感到非常幸运能做到这一点。但我也，我不喜欢在别人的钱上吸取教训。我觉得，你知道，当这笔钱像《碟中谍》、《星际迷航》或《星球大战》那么大时，无论是，你知道，一个小失误还是一个大失误，或者是一件
And literally the day before he asked me, I could never have predicted. I didn't know that was coming at all. Really? At all. He gave me a heads up about it, but I wanted you to be surprised. You didn't want to freak him out. Yeah, I didn't want to freak him out. I wanted it to be special.
我希望，你知道，没有人看到，或者很多人看到本可以不是那样的东西，或者其他什么，这让我怀疑，因为我从来没想过我会制作我小时候就存在的电影版本。我从来没想过那是我要去的地方，我只是因为各种原因被卷入了这些事情，当事情出错时，我责怪任何人，只责怪我自己。但像我喜欢的那些，你知道，我参与过的，很多都是，你知道，通常是那种原创故事，当马特和
We love that. We love the one that you did with Carrie in it. Oh yeah, she was so good in that. But my point though is that I feel like I've gotten incredible opportunities, so I feel very lucky to have done that. But I also, I don't like learning lessons under the people's dimes. And I feel like, you know, when it's a dime as big as, you know, Mission or Star Trek or Star Wars, and whether it is, you know, a little fumble or a big fumble or a thing
我制作《幸福》或者达蒙·林德洛夫和我制作《迷失》时，就像那些故事，你知道，特别有趣，因为它们不是关于扩展一个已经创造出来的宇宙。而是关于从零开始建立一个，这要好得多。对，对。你建立了那个，你建立了很多。你建立了布莱德利·库珀的职业生涯。你给了他一个职业生涯。
that I wished and, you know, no one else sees or a thing that a lot of people saw that could have been what it wasn't or whatever, it makes me wonder because I never in a million years thought I would be doing versions of movies that existed when I was a kid. I never thought that was where I was going to go and I just ended up kind of getting sucked into these things for various reasons and blame no one but myself when things go wrong. But like the things that I love, you know, that I've been involved in are a lot of things that are just, you know, usually the sort of the original stories that when Matt and
这就是我一直对布莱德利说的。他说，我不知道他是不是。我知道。布莱德利应该最终通知他。我只是，我只是在嘲讽他，这样他就会生气到足以过来参加节目。我们马上回来。好的。回到节目。
I did Felicity or Damon Lindelof and I did Lost, it's like those are stories that like, you know, it was especially fun because they weren't about extending a universe that was already created. It was about building one from the ground up, which was much better. Right, right. You built that, and you built that a lot. You built Bradley Cooper's career. You gave him a career.
你不工作的时候会发疯吗？你喜欢保持忙碌吗？你是那种像年轻时一样，只想工作、工作、工作、工作、工作的人吗？是的。但后来你到了一个年龄。你还在那里吗？你是那种，天哪，你知道吗？
That's what I keep saying to Bradley. And he's like, I don't know if he is. I know. Bradley should end up putting him on notice. I'm just, I'm just taunting him so that he'll get mad enough to come and do the show. And we will be right back. Okay. And back to the show.
我无所事事。我不能。我讨厌感到闲着。我需要工作。还是你在享受它？所以威尔之前问你什么时候有时间做音乐？就像，我确实喜欢制作东西。就像我忍不住。
Do you go crazy when you're not working? Do you like to keep busy? Are you one of those people like when you're younger, all you want to do is work, work, work, work, work. Yeah. But then you get into an age. Are you still, are you there yet? Are you like, God, you know what?
所以从事，创作歌曲或者从事，你知道，像字面意义上荒谬的艺术项目，或者像，你知道，我卷入了这种疯狂的模块化合成器东西，这是一个我求你不要进去的兔子洞，因为它字面意义上，它会接管你生活中的一切。那是什么？那是什么？那是什么？
I'm sitting around. I can't. I hate feeling idle. I need to just work. Or are you enjoying it? So Will's earlier question of when do you find time to do music? It's like, I do like making stuff. Like I can't help that.
它看起来像一个，像老式的电话接线员总机，你有这些电缆，你正在连接不同的东西。而且它，它是一种制作音乐的方式。而且它是一种奇怪的冥想般的奇妙的、奇怪的。哇。我想看看那个。它叫什么？模块化合成。
And so working on, on songs or working on, you know, like literally ridiculous art projects or like, you know, I got involved in this crazy modular synthesis thing, which is a rabbit hole I beg you to not go into because it's literally, it will take over everything in your life. What is that? What is it? What is it? What is it?
我可以，我可以给你看，但没人能看到。是的。没关系。我们会描述它。听起来像强尼·格林伍德那种东西。是的。正是那样。令人兴奋。
It looks like a, like an old timey sort of telephone operator switchboard where you have these cables and you're connecting different things. And it's, it's like a means of making music. And it's a bizarrely sort of meditative kind of fantastic, weird. Wow. I want to see that. What's it called? Modular synthesis.
你能看到那个吗？天哪。听众，我们正在看一个，那就像任务控制中心之类的东西。等等，那个，JJ，那个东西能制作音乐？它可以。你有没有考虑过为你自己的东西配乐？我有，但就像我说的，你知道，像我跟人说话时，你知道，迈克尔·吉亚奇诺或者当然像约翰·威廉姆斯，你会觉得，你知道，所有
I could, I could show you, but no one could see it. Yeah. That's okay. We'll describe it. Sounds like Johnny Greenwood kind of stuff. It is. It's exactly that. Exciting.
你只想作为一个人消失，因为这些是真正的大师。所以就像，再次，在像你想要所有你能得到的帮助的类别中，我不知道我为自己的东西配乐是否会，你知道，因为你希望他们提升你的东西，而不是摧毁它。所以让我问你，你之前提到关于，关于你不想在别人的钱上失败。你有什么职业上的遗憾吗，你有像，我们之前在请鲍勃·奥登科克来这里之前谈过一点，他和我都感叹，那部《所罗门兄弟》
Can you see that? Oh my God. Listener, we're looking at a, that's like a mission control type of stuff. Wait, that, that JJ, that thing makes music? It can. Have you ever considered scoring one of your things? I have, but like I said, you know, like I don't know when I'm talking to people like, you know, Michael Giacchino or of course like John Williams and you're like, you know, all
这部我们合作的电影不够好，威尔·福特写的，我们总是，有一个很棒的剧本，我们希望它更好。我的意思是，关于它有一些事情是，我希望我们做了这个。就像，我有如此生动的记忆，就像，我希望在那场戏里，我做了这个，我希望那个。你有那些，你有那些时刻，你有那些，有没有一个场景或什么东西突出，至今仍然困扰你，你希望它不同？我的意思是，首先，我会说这个，我从事的任何事情，都是一个巨大的
you want to do is just disappear as a human because these are actual masters. So it's like, again, in the category of like, you want all the help you can get, I don't know if my scoring my own thing would, you know, because you want them to elevate your stuff, not destroy it. So let me ask you, you mentioned before about, about you not wanting to fail on, on somebody else's dime. Do you have a regret sort of professionally, and do you have like, we talked a little bit before we had Bob Odenkirk on here and he and I were both lamenting that, that Brother
合作。所以我不能说任何特定项目的坏话，而不让它听起来像，像某种糟糕的，你知道，评论。对。我们不会发布一个标题说JJ·艾布拉姆斯，你知道，后悔《星际迷航》、《星球大战》、《幸福》、《双面女间谍》。但选布莱德利是个错误。你已经释放了它。
Solomon, this movie we worked on wasn't better that Will Forte wrote, that we always, there was a great script and we wished it was better. I mean, there were things about it that were like, I wish we had done this. Like, and I have such vivid memories of like, I wish in that scene, I'd done this and I wish that this, do you have those, do you have those moments, do you have those, is there a scene or something that sticks out that still bothers you to this day that you wish was different? I mean, first of all, I will say this, that anything that I have worked on, it's a massive
这是一个巨大的错误。这肯定会成为标题。我们得到了。但答案是100%。是的。当然，在我所做的一切中，我看着某样东西想，哦，我希望这有，你知道，有些时候我希望我足够强大，能对网络说，不，我们还没准备好做这个。
collaboration. So I can't speak ill of any particular project without it coming off as, as some kind of awful, you know, comment. Right. And we're not going to put out a headline that says JJ Abrams, you know, regrets Star Trek, Star Wars, Felicity, Ailee. But casting Bradley was a mistake. You've unleashed it.
我们还没准备好，因为我参与过一些节目，我知道它们有潜力成为某种未实现的东西，因为我们试图取悦一个由某人决定的任意时间表，你知道，想要发布公告，但与它的实际创作无关。我不责怪任何人。你知道，我，这是我的错，对于任何我觉得本可以这样或那样的事情。我的意思是，我愿意认为我们都在前进的过程中做出了我们能做的最好的决定。
It was a huge mistake. It will be the headline for sure. We got it. But the answer is 100 percent. Yes. Of course, there are in everything that I have done, I look at something and think, oh, I wish this had had, you know, there are times I wish I had been stronger enough to say to a network, no, we're not ready to do this.
回顾过去并说，那是你应该说不的时候，或者那是你应该做X或Y的时候，这太容易了。但我对一些项目有大量的那些感觉，有些是整体上的，有些是在项目内部的。天哪，我看着你，我只是想，什么，什么，什么，那一定感觉像制作了好电影。是的。我不，我不分享那个。
We're not ready because there have been shows that I have been involved in that I know had potential to be something that was not realized because we were trying to please an arbitrary timeline that was decided by someone who, you know, wanted to make an announcement, but had nothing to do with the actual creation of it. And I don't blame anyone. You know, I, it's my fault for, for any of the things that I feel like could have gone this way or that. I mean, I'd like to think we all make the best decisions we can as we go.
我，我不知道那个感觉。因为那个，因为那个JJ和所有那些巨大的成功，有没有一个你还没有尝试过的类型？我知道你说你还没涉及喜剧，或者你害怕，因为你可能可以选择任何你想做的事情，而且，那下一件事是什么？有很多电影，就像我相信你们一样，我只是，我爱它，我看着它，我想，天哪，就像那是如此，你知道，你看着像《广播新闻》这样的东西，再次谈论吉姆·布鲁克斯，就像它，它是如此令人难以置信的辉煌
And it's so easy to look back and go, that's when you should have said no, or that's when you should have done X or Y. But I have a ton of those feelings about some holistically about projects and some within them. God, I just look at you and I just think like, what, what, what, that must feel like to have made good movies. Yeah. I don't, I don't share that.
或者《杜丝先生》或《回到未来》或，你知道，这些电影你只是想，神圣，什么鬼？就像什么魔法？就像它，它，它们是如此深刻地好。魔法是对的。你击中了那个，那个词。有，所有那些电影里都有魔法。嗯，但你知道什么，那些电影和一些，
I, I have no idea what, what that sense. Because of that, because of that JJ and all of that tremendous success, is there a genre that you haven't tackled? I know you said you touched on comedy yet or that you're afraid to because you can probably pick anything you want to do and, and what is that next thing? There are so many movies like I'm sure with you guys that I just, I love and I look at it and I think, oh my God, like that is so, you know, you look at something like broadcast news to talk about Jim Brooks again, like it's like, it is so unbelievably brilliant
大型特效电影和一些帐篷杆东西有什么不同，它们确实，你知道，理所当然地驱动我们的业务，你对那些像《广播新闻》或《克莱默夫妇》或《杜丝先生》这样的电影，你知道，不谈达斯汀·霍夫曼的职业生涯，但你对它们存在于流媒体平台上站在哪里，对吧？不是影院上映，有可能这些电影在如今可以更频繁地制作，如果我们都接受也许那些不会获得影院上映。换句话说，它们不需要在大格式中观看。你会愿意制作那些电影，而工作室说，听着，它会去
or tootsie or back to the future or, you know, these movies that you just think, holy, what the fuck? Like what magic? Like it just, it's, they're so deeply good. Magic is right. You hit that, that word. There are, all of those movies have magic in them. Well, but you know what, what's different though about those movies versus some of the,
流媒体，因为这些类型的电影不能驱动那种保证我们必须做出的巨大营销支出的票房出席率？你能从那个词汇沙拉中提取出问题吗？是的。首先，我认为任何允许像你刚才提到的那些一样好的电影以任何格式制作的东西，我认为都是一件好事。太久以来，显然，那种规模的电影一直没有出路。但话虽如此，尽管巴里·迪勒刚才说了关于电影业务
the big sort of effects movies and some are tentpole stuff that really, you know, deservedly drive our business, where do you stand on how those types of movies like a broadcast news or a Kramer versus Kramer or tootsie, you know, not going down Dustin Hoffman's career, but where do you stand on those existing on a streaming platform, right? Not a theatrical release, that there's a possibility that those films could be made more often nowadays if we all accept that maybe those are not going to get a theatrical release. In other words, they don't need to be seen in a large format. Would you be okay making those movies and the studio saying, listen, it's going to go
结束了，那只是阳光的一线，我想，但我认为人类有一种自然的需要，让我们聚集在一起，而不是虚拟地，我认为人们在第一次机会时就冲向餐馆、游戏和酒吧的事实，这是一个人们渴望生活的标志，它不一定像，哦，它会是咆哮的20年代。它可能会，我有点希望它是，但事实是，我认为在床上躺着看iPad上的电影很好，它甚至可能很棒，但正如我们所知，没有什么比在大剧院里人们尖叫更好，它让我想起这个时间，只是因为我不能不每五秒钟谈论一次罗恩·霍华德。
to streaming because these types of movies don't drive the kind of box office attendance that warrants the huge marketing spend that we would have to make? Can you pull the question out of that, that word salad? Yeah. First of all, I think anything that allows a movie that is as good as any of those you just mentioned to get made in any format, I think is a good thing. For too long, obviously, there hasn't been an outlet for that size movie. But having said that, and despite what Barry Diller just said about the movie business
我去看了，这已经是几年前的事了，但他们在加州大学洛杉矶分校放映一部哈罗德·劳埃德的电影，《安全至下》，罗恩在那里，有一个管风琴手在现场演奏音乐，大约有2000人，当我告诉你人们在看这部电影时尖叫，它是在1917年左右制作的，当他爬上钟楼时，就像尖叫。我看了所有那些，它们很搞笑。而且他很棒，顺便说一下，你知道关于他的手的故事吗，顺便说一下，哈罗德·劳埃德？不。
being over, which that was just a ray of sunshine, I thought, but I think that there's a human natural need for us to gather and not virtually, and I think that the fact that people are at the first opportunity rushing to restaurants and games and bars, it is a sign of people hungry to live, and it's not necessarily like, oh, it's going to be the roaring 20s. It might, and I kind of hope it is, but the fact is, I think that watching a movie on your iPad lying in bed is fine, and it could be even great, but as we know, there's nothing as good as being in a big theater and people screaming, it made me think of this time just because I can't not talk about Ron Howard every five seconds.
是的，好吧，他没有，他缺了手指之类的。好吧，你可以，你可以毁了它，抱歉。所以，不，他做了那个。我们会剪掉那个。是的。不，去，你在说什么关于他的手？为什么要请JJ？为什么我们不只是采访肖恩，杰森？
I went to go see, this is now years ago, but they were showing a Harold Lloyd movie, Safety Last at UCLA, and Ron was there, and there was an organist playing the music live, and it was like 2,000 people, and when I tell you that people were screaming at this movie it was made in like 1917 as he's climbing the clock tower, like screaming. I watch all of those, they're hilarious. And he was amazing, and by the way, do you know the story about his hand, by the way, the Harold Lloyd? No.
是的。不，抱歉。等等，我们会假装我们什么都没做。但观众对一部，你知道，你通常不会看的电影感到疯狂，所以我只是认为记住观众对某些时刻的反应，你知道，比尔·默瑞在《杜丝先生》里的反应，或者其他什么，在那个房间里和那些人在一起，有一种力量和记忆，这是你坐在床上看时得不到的。
Yeah, well, that he didn't, that he was missing fingers or something. All right, you can just, you can ruin it, sorry. So, no, he does that. We'll cut that out. Yeah. No, go, what are you talking about his hand? Why have J.J. on? Why don't we just interview Sean, Jason?
我只是觉得，是的，我们可以看电影，但去体验它们。我认为，你知道，在剧院里是最棒的，我希望当我们回到，你知道，世界，希望越快越好，那会变得更受欢迎，那种规模的电影，因为我认为各种规模、形状和形式的电影在流媒体上取得的成功并不意味着它们需要被限制在流媒体上。我认为它们可以，它们可以存在于任何地方。对。那是一个更词汇的回答。
Yeah. No, sorry. Wait, we'll pretend we're not doing anything. But the audience was going insane for a movie that, you know, you would not typically be watching, so I just think remembering the audience reaction to certain moments of, you know, Bill Murray's and Tootsie or something, there's a power and a memory that gets made being in that room with those people that you just don't get when you're sitting on your bed watching.
不，我喜欢它。你能给我们一点，你刚才说的所有这些，你能给我们一点点关于你接下来要做什么的片段，你对什么感到超级兴奋？是的。我写了一个试播集，我正在HBO执导，叫《半世界》，我们将在明年年初拍摄。什么是《半世界》？
And I just feel like, yes, we can see movies, but to experience them. I think that, you know, being in the theaters is the greatest, and I'm hoping as we go back, you know, to the world, hopefully sooner than later, that that will become more popular and that movies of that size, because I think the success that all sorts of size and shape and form movies are having on streaming doesn't mean that they need to be limited to streaming. I think they can, they could exist anywhere. Right. That was a more word shall and answer.
这对我们来说是一部大动作剧，我希望，在不谈论故事的情况下，因为我不想，任何我开始谈论的东西都是垃圾。是什么类型？它，它是一个如此奇怪的类型。就像当我想到我最喜欢的电影时，它们通常是这些奇怪的组合。就像我喜欢的，我的意思是，它可能与此不同，但就像《美国狼人在伦敦》，对我来说，就像，如果士力架巧克力棒是一部电影，它就是那个。
No, I love it. And can you give us a little, all of that that you just said, can you give us the tiny bit of a little nugget of what's coming up next for you, what you were super excited about working on? Yes. I'm going to, I wrote a pilot that I'm directing at HBO called Demi-Mond that we are going to shoot early next year. What's Demi-Mond?
它是完美的标本。是的。记住，记住《异形》就像一部恐怖片，但在太空中，就像，等等，什么？当然现在就像，嗯，它是《异形》，当然，但在当时，它是一个疯狂的混搭。所以这是一个不同类型的混搭，但我真正喜欢的是角色。而且我，再次，我很高兴能从事一个原创概念的工作。JJ·艾布拉姆斯，我们什么时候可以期待看到那个？
It's a big swing show for us that I hope, without getting to the story, because I don't, anything I start talking about was on shitty. What's the genre? It is, it's such a weird one. It's like, it's a funny thing when I think about my favorite movies, they're usually these weird combos of things. Like I loved, I mean, it could be more different than this, but like American World from London, for me, is like, if a Snickers bar were a movie, it would be that.
我会说明年年底。太棒了。肖恩。我很兴奋。不错。而且你，在我们让你走之前谈谈，因为我们感谢你的时间。谈谈家庭，因为太忙了，有时在现场拍摄，没有灵活性来回奔波。
It's the perfect specimen. Yeah. Remember, remember Alien was like a horror film, but in space, it was like, wait, what? And of course now it's like, well, it's the Alien, of course, but at the time, it was a crazy mashup. So this is a bit of a mashup of different genres, but it's the characters that I really love. And I, again, I'm thrilled to be working on something that is an original concept. And JJ Amrums, when can we expect to see that?
还有，你和凯蒂有机会一起工作，就像那一定是一种快乐，你们不必在每天开始时分开，回来，你知道？这是我认为坏机器人，我们的公司，能运作的一个非常重要的部分，是因为凯蒂在其中和为它所做的一切工作。而且它确实偶尔会击中我，大多数人没有机会，而且很多人不想有机会与他们的伴侣如此密切地工作。但对我来说，与我非常信任的人一起工作的想法，或者你最信任的人，
I would say end of next year. Fantastic. Sean. I'm excited. Nice. And are you, talk a little bit before we let you go, because we thank you for this time. Talk a little bit about family being so busy, shooting on location sometimes, not having the flexibility to come back and forth.
它仍然无法与与凯蒂一起工作相比，我知道我们有共同的，我们所有的利益都是一致的。但家庭部分是，我只是依靠大流行病说，看，我们只是要一年，一年半。不，事实是，有时这是一种压力，你做某些事情，比如在《原力觉醒》上，我们的女儿和朋友跟我去了伦敦，所以她在《最后一部星球大战电影》上待了相当长一段时间。我们的大儿子跟我去了，就像，我们想出了办法试图让它更好地工作。
Also with that, the incredible opportunity that you and Katie have to be working together, like how much of a joy that must be that you guys don't have to separate at the beginning of every day and come back to get, you know? It's a hugely important part of why I think Bad Robot, our company, works at all is because of all the work that Katie does in it and for it. And it does hit me every once in a while that most people don't get the opportunity to, and that a lot of people don't want the opportunity to get to work as closely with their partner. But to me, the idea of working with someone who I trust a lot, or you trusted the most,
但这只是很难。而且正如你们都知道的，有一个家庭，你知道，在某个年龄，你不能只是搬走。是的，因为他们想要他们的社交和学校连续性，100%。所以事实是，这是一个挑战。除了两部《星球大战》电影，你知道，我没有在洛杉矶以外拍摄任何东西，除了这里那里几周。所以我实际上没有离开过。
it still wouldn't compare to working with Katie, who I just know we have mutual, all our interests are aligned. But the family part is, I just rely on pandemics to say, look, we're just going to be a year, year and a half. No, the truth is, it's a strain sometimes you do certain things like on Force Awakens, our daughter came with me to London with a friend, so she was there for quite a bit on The Last Star Wars Movie. Our oldest son came with me, like, we've figured out ways to try and make it work better.
那两部电影就像两年，所以它不像一个闪现。但我猜我会说这个，这对我来说是一个如此重要的价值，知道我想成为什么样的父母。而且我相信正如我们所有人一样，我们只是在搞砸，犯下我们无法量化的错误。但我感觉有时刻当我与我们的三个孩子中的任何一个在一起时。我只是感谢宇宙那些时刻存在，而且我们像我们一样亲密。而且我确实认为，不开玩笑，大流行病是这个疯狂的激励，你知道，带着所有
But it's just hard. And as you all know, having a family that, you know, at a certain age, you can't just like up and move. Yeah, because they want their social and school continuity and 100%. So the truth is, it's been a challenge. And except for the two Star Wars movies, you know, I haven't shot anything outside of LA with the exception of a few weeks here and there. So I've actually not been away.
但这确实很难。正如你们所知，有了家庭之后，孩子到了某个年龄，你就不能说走就走。是的，因为他们需要社交和学校生活的连续性，这一点百分之百正确。所以事实是，这一直是个挑战。除了那两部《星球大战》电影，你知道，我几乎没有在洛杉矶以外的地方拍过戏，偶尔也就几周时间。所以我其实并没有离开过。
Those two movies were like two years, so it's not like a blip. But I guess I'll say this is that it's just such an important value to me, knowing kind of what sort of parent I wanted to be. And I'm sure as we all are, we are just fucking it up and making mistakes that we can't possibly quantify. But I feel like there are moments when I'm with any one of our three kids. And I just thank the universe that those moments exist and that we are as close as we are. And I do think no joke that the pandemic was this crazy galvanizing, you know, with all
那两部电影拍了大概两年，所以这不仅仅是一瞬间的事。但我想说的是，这对我来说是一个非常重要的价值观，因为我知道自己想成为什么样的父母。我相信我们所有人都在努力，虽然我们肯定会搞砸，会犯下无法估量的错误。但我觉得，每当我与三个孩子中的任何一个在一起时，我都会感谢宇宙，感谢这些时刻的存在，感谢我们之间如此亲密。而且我真心觉得，疫情确实是一个疯狂的催化剂，你知道，尽管有种种困难。
the pain and agony for so many people during it. I've heard from a lot of people, and I think we felt this too, one positive that came from it is just you could not help but get closer. And it was just that was the beautiful aspect of it. Yeah. And that was my experience too. And we, I will say this, that again, kind of going off what you were saying that, yeah, of course, there were so many people around the world who suffered a great deal.
在那期间，很多人都经历了痛苦和折磨。我从很多人那里听说，我想我们也感受到了，其中一个积极的方面就是你不得不变得更亲近。这就是它美好的一面。是的，这也是我的经历。而且我想说，就像你刚才说的，当然，世界上有很多人遭受了巨大的痛苦。
And so not to minimize that at all. But for my family, my own personal experience, because we live in a world where we just only talk about our own experience. And if it doesn't line up with my experience, then fuck you. It's not really ugly. But I know, well, I guess with me, it gets ugly quick and out of nowhere. I didn't realize I was in a pitch black room and that turns are often violent. But, but, but, but it was a great, it was a great, yeah, in a lot of ways it was a great,
所以并不是要淡化这一点。但对于我的家庭，我个人的经历来说，因为我们生活在一个只谈论自己经历的世界里。如果它不符合我的经历，那就去你的。这并不丑陋。但我知道，好吧，我想对我来说，它很快就会变得丑陋，而且毫无征兆。我没意识到我身处一个漆黑的房间里，而转折往往是暴力的。但是，但是，但是，但是，这很棒，这很棒，在很多方面这都是一次很棒的，
it was a great experience for us too. There's our quote. We got it. No, but I was going to say the quote is, is really that JJ loves show business more than his kids. And, and, and I think hats off because I, it's not for me to judge you and Jason wants to know he wants you to make it okay for him to feel the same way. And so once we get you signed off, because you're really a Titan in this industry, then
这对我们来说也是一次很棒的经历。这就是我们的引语。我们得到了。不，但我本来想说的是，那句引语确实是JJ爱演艺事业胜过爱他的孩子。而且，而且，而且我认为要向他致敬，因为我不该评判你，而Jason想知道，他想让你让他觉得有这种感觉是可以的。所以一旦我们让你签了名，因为你确实是这个行业的泰坦，那么
he'll be okay and he'll be have enough success to be nice to people. Well, JJ, thanks for coming on this show. Seriously, JJ, thank you for being here. You're so kind. It's such an honor. We're all such huge fans. It's amazing. I'm such a fan of yours and the podcast as a whole.
他就会没事的，他也会有足够的成功来对人友善。好吧，JJ，谢谢你来参加这个节目。说真的，JJ，谢谢你来到这里。你太客气了。这真是太荣幸了。我们都是你的超级粉丝。这太棒了。我是你和整个播客的超级粉丝。
It's truly is. So you should charge guests. Oh, you're getting invoiced. You're getting invoiced. You should have the guests do one of the commercials. You really should. I know. We'd love to do that.
确实如此。所以你应该向嘉宾收费。哦，你会收到发票的。你会收到发票的。你应该让嘉宾做其中一个广告。你真的应该这样做。我知道。我们很乐意这样做。
That's a good thing. I'm going to get you in here. No joke. Thank you so much for having me on. Oh my God. Thank you. JJ, thank you. Thank you, pal.
那是一件好事。我要把你拉进来。不开玩笑。非常感谢你邀请我来。哦天哪。谢谢。JJ，谢谢。谢谢你，伙计。
We love you. It's so much fun and you guys are awesome. Thank you. So are you, man. Have a good day. I hope to see you all in person soon. Me too. All right.
我们爱你。这太有趣了，你们太棒了。谢谢。你也是，伙计。祝你今天愉快。希望很快能亲自见到你们所有人。我也是。好的。
Thank you. Bye. Bye. All right. So I said to Will a couple of days ago that, you know, I was listening to the podcast and the time we sign off with a guest, you know, they go away. We just go into this big puff piece kind of like, oh, aren't they great? And so down to earth and all this shit.
谢谢。再见。再见。好的。所以我几天前对Will说，你知道，我在听播客，每次我们和嘉宾告别时，你知道，他们就离开了。我们就进入这种大肆吹捧的模式，比如，哦，他们不是很好吗？而且那么脚踏实地，所有这些废话。
We mean it. Oh, I'm sorry, Will. Should we wait? We'll take a tight five while you eat. You know? Jesus Christ. But now, but there goes JJ and I can't think of anything but just the most puffy. You're the one who brought this up and now you're doing it.
我们是认真的。哦，对不起，Will。我们要等一下吗？你吃的时候我们休息五分钟。你知道吗？天哪。但现在，JJ走了，我除了想到最吹捧的话之外什么也想不出来。是你提出来的，现在你却在做。
Like we, I guess it's just, maybe it's our fault because we're, we book nice people. Yeah. And I don't have a nasty thing to say. I don't want to say it. No. He's just great. For me, you know, I, like I said, we, I see JJ socially, but I never get to fan freak out on him like about it.
就像我们，我想这只是，也许是我们的错，因为我们，我们预订的都是好人。是的，我没有什么坏话要说。我不想说。不。他就是很棒。对我来说，你知道，就像我说的，我们，我在社交场合见过JJ，但我从来没有机会像粉丝那样对他疯狂。
You guys have game nighters and we talk about socially. What's going on? What do you mean you see him socially? What are you doing? No, not a lot. What are you trying to, what are you trying to hide? I see him socially. By the way, I wore my Tatooine hat today.
你们有游戏之夜，我们在社交场合谈论。发生了什么？你什么意思你在社交场合见到他？你在做什么？不，没那么多。你想，你想隐瞒什么？我在社交场合见到他。顺便说一句，我今天戴了我的塔图因帽子。
I just noticed that. God, that's embarrassing. Jason, do you even know what that is? Sure. I see it on, on dork chat every once in a while when I watch. Yeah. Listener, Sean's wearing, wearing a Star Wars hat. Tatooine.
我刚注意到。天哪，太尴尬了。Jason，你知道那是什么吗？当然。我偶尔看的时候在书呆子聊天室里看到过。是的。听众，Sean戴着，戴着一顶星球大战帽子。塔图因。
A real deep cut one that just says where it was, isn't that where the Ewoks live? Do I have that right? No, it's where Luke Skywalker lives. Asshole. See? So I get kicked out of dork chat. But, but so for me, like, I try to say something nasty about JJ. You can't, you can't.
一个真正的深度梗，上面写着它在哪里，那不是伊沃克人住的地方吗？我没说错吧？不，那是卢克·天行者住的地方。混蛋。看吧？所以我被踢出了书呆子聊天室。但是，但是对我来说，我想说JJ的坏话。你不能，你不能。
I revere him like, like people do Spielberg. You know, that's a, that's, he's a great interview, a real hero of mine. My God. Yeah. Jason, you're a director. Do you ever want to do big stuff like that, like JJ does? Of course. Of course I would.
我崇拜他，就像人们崇拜斯皮尔伯格一样。你知道，那是一个，他是一个很棒的采访对象，是我真正的英雄。天哪。是的。Jason，你是一位导演。你有没有想过做像JJ那样的大制作？当然。我当然想。
I mean, but, and that's kind of why I was asking him, like, if I ever got one of those calls that he got, you know, the one day he's not doing Mission Impossible, the next day he gets a phone call to go direct, like, what? Oh, okay. Am I capable? Would you, would you step in one of those franchises though? In a second. In a second.
我的意思是，但这正是为什么我问他，如果我接到他接到的那些电话，你知道，有一天他没在拍《碟中谍》，第二天他接到电话去执导，就像，什么？哦，好吧。我有能力吗？你会，你会介入那些特许经营项目吗？一秒钟。一秒钟。
I would. Let me ask you this, because you, you are starting to really establish yourself as a director and a really good director and a sought after director. That's nice of you. Well, it's true. And you're really, you're really, really good director. And I give you a lot of shit about Ozark, but you're really good. And you can tell the episodes.
我会的。让我问你这个，因为你，你开始真正确立自己作为导演的地位，而且是一位非常优秀的导演，一位炙手可热的导演。你太客气了。好吧，这是真的。而且你真的是，非常非常好的导演。我给了你很多关于《黑钱胜地》的废话，但你真的很棒。你可以看出那些剧集。
And I don't mean this as an upfront to the other directors. I can tell the episodes that you direct because you pay attention to all the right things. And I do like the way you and I joke. We hate the term storyteller, but you do tell great story. I know. God, don't even say it. But I will say this. So then you see a guy like JJ Abrams who you guys are not dissimilar.
我并不是要冒犯其他导演。我能看出你执导的剧集，因为你关注所有正确的事情。我确实喜欢你我开玩笑的方式。我们讨厌“讲故事的人”这个词，但你确实讲了很棒的故事。我知道。天哪，别说了。但我会说这一点。所以你看到像JJ·艾布拉姆斯这样的人，你们并不像。
You both grew up in LA. You both have, he was, you know, great hair. Great hair. Well, he's like, he was a writer and a director and you were a performer, but you guys both ended up in this, in similar lanes. He is servicing to Sean's point of movies that other people came up with a lot of like, he's doing a lot of Star Trek and Star Wars and huge and he does it really, really, really well. Imagine what it would be like.
你们都在洛杉矶长大。你们都有，他，你知道，很棒的头发。很棒的头发。好吧，他就像，他是一位编剧和导演，而你是一位表演者，但你们最终都走上了相似的道路。他正在服务于Sean提到的那些别人想出来的电影，比如，他做了很多《星际迷航》和《星球大战》，而且非常非常非常出色。想象一下那会是什么样子。
And he kind of touched on doing this pilot where he gets to do tell his own story. I think it's incumbent upon him to bring back the Tutsis. It's on him to bring back those great movies that we talked about, the networks, all that stuff. Yeah. I would way rather than see you step into one of these franchises that I don't want to. I would just love to challenge myself with just the responsibility and, you know, no matter what the movie was, it's just the process of going right to the edge of what I think I can handle.
他谈到了制作这个试播集，他可以讲述自己的故事。我认为他有责任带回图西族。带回我们谈论过的那些伟大的电影，电视网，所有这些东西是他的责任。是的。我宁愿看到你介入这些我不想参与的特许经营项目。我只是很想挑战自己，承担责任，你知道，无论是什么电影，这只是一个过程，直接走到我认为我能处理的极限。
I get that part of it, but there are, we do live in a time, I think JJ is right, we do it live in a time where movies can really come back in a real way and we have a chance now to reset. But I think that's what streaming and, frankly, Netflix is allowing for. You can make these smaller movies that aren't super sticky and loud conceptually and all that stuff. There's a place for them now. Well, yeah.
我理解那一部分，但确实有，我们确实生活在一个时代，我认为JJ是对的，我们确实生活在一个电影可以真正以一种真实的方式回归的时代，我们现在有机会重置。但我认为这就是流媒体，坦率地说，Netflix所允许的。你可以制作这些不那么粘人、概念上也不那么吵闹的小电影。现在有它们的一席之地了。好吧，是的。
Well, would you please make it and you and JJ. I write totally, but I have to say in this country, once you introduce a convenience, it's hard to take it away and that convenience has been introduced. I think both can co-exist and I think the industry can still be healthy and co-exist. Co-exist. Co-exist. Oh, that's what your bumper sticker meant. Yeah.
好吧，你愿意制作它吗，你和JJ。我完全同意，但我必须说在这个国家，一旦你引入了一种便利，就很难将其拿走，而那种便利已经被引入了。我认为两者可以共存，我认为这个行业仍然可以健康并共存。共存。共存。哦，这就是你的保险杠贴纸的意思。是的。
Oh, with the co-exist. Now that car, that car that you had the bumper sticker on, did you lease that or did you sell? Bye! Smart. Last. Smart. Last.
哦，关于共存。现在那辆车，你贴保险杠贴纸的那辆车，你是租的还是卖了？再见！聪明。最后。聪明。最后。
The next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music or by subscribing to Wondery Plus in the Wondery app. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjolf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grant Terry. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下一集将在一周后发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过在Wondery应用程序中订阅Wondery Plus来收听。SmartLess是由Rob Armjolf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Grant Terry手工制作的100%有机和艺术品。SmartLess。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。